pulled up to calabasas ready for where i
might turn to a savage i just showed up
with the crewy the baddest you just
showed up like you might need some
practice
you going down for the count it's going
down tonight i do it all for my family
you do it all for the likes i hit that
bell and i'm ready to fight turn me up
turn me up turn me up they want the belt
they don't work and know don't mess
around and i'm hurting them i say the
wrong thing make it personal you say the
wrong thing i might hurt them all
yeah
a lot of energy we are live a lot of
energy we are live
calabasas fight companion for ufc 273
to my left we got the old big gay l
they're all big gay we call him rinks
you might know him as the man dragon
i just call him daddy it's brian callan
yeah call me daddy man dragon the least
tough guy at this table
well i don't know that's up for debate
then mma royalty over there bellator's
finest you know him from weighing in
josh thompson making a has a return has
one of the most historic high kicks of
all time yes you know against nate is
mm-hmm yeah there's a lot of highlights
i think he only got
kind of like out of frame almost i'm
very happy with that hunter green that
whatever that green is oh you know you
know what he did to match my fry i did i
picked him up in a fry from his hotel i
went oh oh you matching oh that's that's
i don't even check my hair
i was blowing through the wind baby yeah
dude you're cutie pie i looked at that
as we're cruising down calabasas road i
went i'm you're not mad at this life
yeah
let's talk about top down sun in his
eyes it was called calabasas road or
whatever dude you're dark today you're
brown yeah i was outside for four hours
running in the mud you were what am i
doing dude so matt this is this [ __ ]
matt so we had tough mudder today thick
mudder matt yesterday goes dude you run
the tough mudder i want to do it i go
when's that same day cardi goes i don't
know i'm down hey three hours goes by i
go cool dudes i'm gonna sign up you can
come with me i'll pick you up we'll
write down together it's cool
a few hours go by this uh 5k or 15 kgo i
can only do the 15 kos oh jesus christ
go don't worry have fun yeah
he's like don't worry it's not that big
of a deal we're gonna have a great time
nobody goes hard
nine miles deal yeah
dude did you know that
did you did you look that up what did
you get
yeah i'm just good at math cats
yeah so nine miles right so uh we so
first of all nine miles that's a long
time i'm arthritic not gonna be awesome
but we decided to go through the [ __ ]
mountains like dude this is nine miles
of straight upward trajectory and then
declined to drop
and so so we go through this thing right
and first of all brendan when we get
there the lady's like hey man everybody
blah blah so nice to see you guys they
love brandon love them all other pieces
you know whatever
all these cute little things come up
giving them hugs whatever hey you're so
fit blah blah blah blah blah blah are
you ready for this shirt
yeah yeah
i'm talking about that you know
i beard my my dudes with chicks
so anyway so they're all loving up on
them telling them how great he's doing
whatever else and they're like hey guys
just let you know
you can't skip any of the uh obstacles
you guys got to do them all everybody
else can skip but you guys can't
what
what are you serious man so we go up so
we do the first one right so we go first
of all it was like i was literally out
of breath running up to the starting
gate because they were already there
like he just disappeared because he's
famous you don't run yeah so we like i
gotta do like a pep talk yeah i gotta
get them back all right everybody you're
a leader so
he's up there he gives a little speech
national anthem plays go it's from the
from 17 steps after the gate it's
[ __ ] like this yeah dude and i was
like you're not ready for that what is
going on here dude and they're trotting
up this thing i'm gonna do i can't i'm
285 pounds i can't do this right now no
way
have you ever done one no dude as we
started going it was like this starts
always like as we started going i looked
at mark i go it could be a long day with
matt here yeah i'm not gonna laugh
pound man now you know but his thing is
yeah he's so athletic yeah so athletic i
was like he's gonna figure out he's
gonna make it even if he walks he could
do it if he really but then his body
just started breaking oh dude it was
ridiculous like i said heavily arthritic
so we get up to we we go to the first
it takes forever by the way to get to
the first obstacle because the obstacle
it's like a water thing you jump in it
you fall you're blowing something out
you get over the top he waited for me
because he loves me yeah we get through
our feet are wet then as soon as we get
done that thing they go up extra steep
hill they have ropes to climb up they
jump over this thing right yeah and then
you go up a super incline flatten out
super incline again right yeah then
up the second incline
there's a [ __ ] pit stop where you
have to pick up sandbags and walk around
this extra thing in the middle of the
steep incline there's a bunch and then
there's a bunch of them it's also 90
degrees then when you put the thing down
you have to finish the incline and then
do piggyback rides across this uneven
terrain what and i was like i'm done no
and you and you have skinny legs so yeah
yeah i got chicken sticks maybe he has
some that's his awesome quads no that's
i'm kidding that's no no i guess
that's his weakness that he uh the other
day all i said we were at the bar and i
go he looks great and that all i do is i
go your legs are kind of skinny and he
goes my guy i'm skinny my legs look
skinny they're actually skinny i realize
oh that's dude that's how about they
have this one partner piggyback so you
gotta jump on somebody's back carry him
through the [ __ ] thing and then
switch and uh mark him marcos i thought
i was gonna have to carry him but then
mark looks like hey man you wanna jump
in mega goes dude i'm 280 pounds mark
goes i don't care i'll do it and i was
like yeah i'll do it
i'll see you on the other side yeah
listen because i know as soon as you
step on something like this 285 pounds
is blowing it all inside you know what
yeah your knees yeah hey so the very
first tough mudder i ever did you've
done them yeah i've done it why the [ __ ]
you do it today did you do the 15k no
one called me or do you wrote did you do
5k don't do it let's do it again did you
do it yeah yeah i feel like josh could
do it
before him yeah
these are the spartans too yeah
spartan's different spartan to me is not
as it's not it's not it's not as hard
tough mudder's a little bit more have
you done one yeah i've done three of
those what i don't know the difference
between the two
spartans more time more more i'd say
more crossfit endurance right yeah but
they also do like a metal thing are you
a crosstalker no i own a couple of gyms
so like fitness gyms but no they do um
different types of
like they give like medals for like
there's one that's like you have to do
this metal it's like a different type of
workout this type this this one here
this next one is like a different type
of exercise different types of other
stuff so like they have one that's like
the one you did today where they carry
like sandbags up a hill and then you you
know get down to the bottom it's more
like that [ __ ] with spartans yeah yeah
that's more somebody's just like fun
yeah like we're in the mud did you even
get in the mud
285 pound guy on the planet you don't
have any fat on you i've never seen you
this lean
well i'm going to jump on this new
carnivore diet i sold my carnivore today
he did yeah he did
you've been doing that because i have
muscles but you can't see them so that
kind of hurts my feelings so i want to
try to have muscles that you can see
yeah so the first time i did this tough
mudder let's go back to the original
stuff yeah yeah the first one is digress
hey before you go on you look are you
are you cutting weight no you look like
benjamin button like you just keep going
around you look better the older you get
i keep getting haircuts you get covered
or something why are you so skinny no no
no oh you look good
you know what because you're sitting
next to [ __ ] mac no
i know josh he looks like you've been
dieting or something working out
yeah i've actually been able to work out
man i [ __ ] my wrist stuff okay so so
we went so i did this one in patterson
up and up in the center like near fresno
area and uh this military guy he was
there with his buddies buddies lost his
legs in the military he kid you not this
guy was in a wheelchair the guy pulled
him jesus
pulled him up that hill
like you're talking about he pulled him
up and then there was yeah like six
other guys with him just taking terms
just getting them he did the whole thing
man they lifted him up over the walls
they they put him up there he did all
the monkey bar stuff by himself the the
handlebar stuff and that's what we're
gonna have to do for us when he does it
everyone
that's low
i
that's
volleyball i play [ __ ] sand
volleyball you guys because that works
for four hours
invited you
did you would have done it for sure you
would have questions for sure how did
you do them all the time right let me
know if you put on sunblock because
you're
tomorrow down in manhattan beach daddy's
going to be playing some [ __ ] some
sandwiches they get serious down there
and if you guys want to come i was
playing next to pros do you play
basketball at all no play basketball
golf golf bowling golf
tennis
you're not baseball softball hold on
hold on tell them the truth if you play
golf you play with your dad twice a year
okay play with my dad twice here
i mean is that your name is golf your
thing with your father like yeah that's
what it is your dad golf a lot at 81
years old he's still working on a stroke
at 81. he's like i might i've figured
out i wasn't moving my shoulders golf is
one of those things never but he's never
stopped working on it my dad improved in
his i swear to god my dad improved
dramatically in the 70s yeah because
he's probably more relaxed
there's also no muscle to get in the way
you know play golf golf every [ __ ]
day casey
that kid plays all the time so i'm going
to tell you something you're [ __ ]
cool um
i'm so arrogant i'm so arrogant yeah
that i actually do believe that even
though i i do not play golf they could
crash it
that i'm going to get on the senior pga
i believe you just believe that i
believe it i like your uh
michael jordan my i'm really good
friends with this caddy michael jordan
his short game is outstanding and for
all the the practice he's done over the
years and he takes it seriously and
plays 36 holes every [ __ ] you know
day he still isn't close to what those
guys on the tour are yeah with their
long with the longest even even tony
romo you know he was like trying out for
the pros
and he plays all the and he's a scratch
golfer yeah it doesn't matter
people don't realize how good those
[ __ ] this is what you have to
remember so jason jason dave is not not
a super big guy hit his [ __ ] seven
iron 246.
that right there told me right there i
have no chance whatsoever no i don't
speak spanish
yeah yeah
yeah i must be golf yeah yeah but you're
saying your seminar normally goes like
for an average person probably like one
160 yeah 150 to 175. somewhere in there
yeah who hey casey you guys hit it at
246. casey who's the bro uh golfer i
like him
big guy yeah he's not a big guy though
he's
they hate each other but why do they
hate each
other bros now they played on the ryder
cup together they had a match
head-to-head brooks won they swatched
the beat
that's probably why because brooks won
yeah but is it because he plays slow is
that why
yeah yeah people were telling me because
he plays slow he takes him forever he
gets up he waddles in front of the ball
dude he steps away and gets back up and
waddles again there's one time one time
in practice against alistair overeem
that hit my liver the only time out of
everybody i fight lucky right so like
it's always like it's exposed yeah no an
uppercut oh god no it was a knee
which one was it dude [ __ ] it was it was
the knee because he kept trying to hit
him with another cut like a hook he kept
trying to hit it oh yeah and then he
switched off every hit possible oh dude
it was an elbow like and i and over him
and i didn't get along for a long time
now but ding for a long time
and like uh hit me hit my liver and i
was like was it was it steroid over and
you didn't get it
was it was this in florida
like you know those are the harder words
to get along with
i can't do it i was so pissed off wait
so he just he dropped you oh dude i
fought it for probably six seconds with
a liver that's impressive six seconds me
he goes hard in practice too oh entirely
dude that amsterdam i've heard stories
of guys like uh hector lumbar to her
yeah
yeah dude
so one time i'm down in florida right
the first time we come down to florida i
know that came in uh dan great dude was
like uh he's like hey man said come on
to our gym and uh okay cool bye time to
go the only person to train with around
my size is hector lombard so he's like
hey do you want to grapple i hear
stories
sherman i'll go ahead and grab with you
dude dives in for reverse heel hooks
seven times in the first half she's like
literally as soon as he goes i tap so he
goes six times in a row i tap i get up
and walk out i've had enough that was it
yeah you're like i'm cool man yeah i'm
not going to learn anything yeah no it's
just already such a set like i've heard
too like
i and i love hector
i love him he's a nice guy he just goes
hard in the paint yeah that's also
old-school mentality
he was super gentle was it really yeah
interesting but [ __ ] aka you guys are
notoriously known for it we don't hurt
people like that you don't hurt each
other you guys go hard in the paint
though yeah we're not hitting the
reverse hill hooks no that's that's
insane yeah guys you guys just get hurt
because what happens is the mats get
real sweaty guys starts you know
shooting you guys spar hard and he goes
back we do spark back in the day that
happens though too they still park they
still
change lumbar was not att right for a
long time
you know i stopped sparring right like a
long time ago and i didn't spar almost
my entire career after that
the reason is is we're in practice and
one of our teammates we're doing mma
gloves just kind of moving around
through uh like superman kick so he
threw like a right high kick and pulled
it back and then threw it right over the
top broke my overall bone jesus and i
was like
what am i supposed to do and then it was
broken when we fought and um and i think
it was after our fight that i was like
hey my my fight got broken my i got
broken in a fight so oh so they covered
it because i couldn't say it happened
with phil dufrese because it was such a
quick fight yeah and then you were my
next one and i said i've broken that
fight
wait wait wait matt what what you don't
did i break it or yeah i think it was
all your power thanks man i don't think
i a single punch when you don't when you
don't spar like i love the fact that i
smirked at you with that and you were
like [ __ ] and took me yeah yeah
threw a combo and smiled at me like oh
i took him down when you when you uh
when you were better 207
i'm sure it'll pay good but like
but uh you've trained with i've trained
with gilbert you've trained with gilbert
definitely more recently when i when i
was training with gilbert he was just a
jiu-jitsu coach he was even mma how
old-school i am um gilbert's is a is a
is a tough ass dude great wall work
really good wah work really good in
close like a lot of dirty boxing get
back in a lot of
um gilbert burns yeah he's fighting homs
right because pressure
yeah i'll just invite him a couple of
times were you yeah i've been a good
fight yeah he was so adamant because i
feel like he's so much bigger than you
josh yeah he he is he's enormous we ran
into him one time and we're like
hey what's up
match against uh lovato junior hatfield
lovato jr i mean and
it was my size yeah exactly and think
about this so gilbert's a thick dude and
hamza is towers no did you see homs out
in him in the s and he's like oh you're
a little guy yeah i'm that beefy dude
fights do you hear what uh dana said and
to me it's like this is you know
obviously dana they you know the ufc i
bet if you ask daniel like okay who do
you want to win here he'd say hom's out
all day because in the i've never seen
deuce ever in the pre-presser he goes if
hamza were to get by gilbert burns we're
gonna do hamza kobe compton on abc
don't get it twisted you're still a
number two guy in the world yeah
gilbert's like i do think he's gonna get
annihilated but
there's an argument where it's like
gilbert might be a better striker his j
his submissions are better
hamzad's bigger
wrestling's way better
my heart's gonna be beating fast
gilbert's gonna be faster gilbert's
gonna have a harder time getting on the
inside because he is shorter he doesn't
have the reach i think
takes them down within
i think he's going to stand with him i
don't think he's going to take him out i
think he will take him down as the fight
progresses
out wins either first or second round
via tko
i think it's going gonna be difficult
for gilbert to get inside but i think
that he's gonna he's gonna try to use a
lot of pressure uh i think he's gonna
take chain wrestling a lot of shots uh
back back back and i think he's trying
to get him against the wall and then do
something from there you just gotta be
careful who's this guy matson was an
olympian wrestler yeah
really stud wrestler nice dude yeah good
wrestler used a lot of energy though
when he wrestles really stud wrestling
yeah yeah really decorated um does his
wrestling translate
yes it does translate he just uses a lot
of energy when he's when he's getting
the takedowns though but i feel
hey why is it in dc on the broadcast
tonight do you know no i don't know i
guess he's somewhere in miami though
right now so i don't know what's going
on probably naked running something i
mean in public don't know i'd be great
you gotta love that might be something
to do with the masters is the master's
down that way
in georgia
he's out somewhere does he give up the
ufc pay-per-view for that though maybe
it's a abc thing
is it bad that's my second drink of uh i
think he's also taking i think he's also
taking they're gonna push
you just gave it up i'm i'm i'm not in
the red wine i might i might get into
some books what's your nationality
italian and irish
50 50. yeah i [ __ ] knew you possibly
put a light on there i knew come on
come on puppy we're gonna do this one
today did this room just get a little
clean you're not you didn't fly did this
room just get a little smaller did his
room just get a little smaller because
he's like bro we're waiting
i suffer from peer pressure so if i have
to start drinking whiskey i will i don't
know why you wouldn't yeah he he's super
decorated i'm pretty sure he won a gold
medal in the olympics twice jesus christ
bro yeah he's a monster [ __ ] this guy
say it again yeah well i'll tell you
what i will say splish splash i was
taking a bath and notice i have
beautiful nuts gentlemen you do our
friends at manscape the global leader
and below the waist hygiene are turning
men's shower dreams into their favorite
routine with the all-new ultra premium
collection this all-in-one hygiene skin
and hair bundle is designed to upgrade
the everyday man shower routine from
head to toe your skin in here and balls
deserve this save big by going to
manscape.com for 20 off and free
shipping with the code cfc
i love it yeah we got it all man what do
you need what do you need bomb do two in
one shampoo and conditioner we make it
easy on you man they have lip balm they
got freaking lotion i could use
something so bad on my face right now
it's very burnt right now
and then you know they got the trimmers
the bundle will change your life again
get 20 off and free shipping with the
code cfc at manscape.com that's 20 off
and free shipping with the code cfc
manscape.com it's time to get wet and
clean with your new manscape shower
routine
all right back to the program let me ask
this question here straight up honest
yup do you guys wear a deodorant silver
medal every single day really i'm not a
hippie man yeah
i am one of the cleanest people i know
but i don't wear doing that why the loom
i've never smelled no no
the aluminum tears aluminum but like
honestly like i just i don't like
wearing dinner i think
that in my mind
i am you can also buy the non-a little
aluminum
and my wife likes my funk she's like hey
when i put on the order she's like
what'd you put on do it for today like
she likes
that b.o like musk she likes it you got
a musky scent oh she's a dirty dirty
girl because you're a rutten boar you
rut like a boar you're keep talking you
[ __ ] you 50 50
we're both going green god if we were on
a [ __ ] island i'd have to run away
from you but you'd probably catch me you
wouldn't go too far beach volleyball i'd
be like i'm straight i'm serious you'd
be playing with with uh with wilson over
there probably this guy's very excited
well that's that's a dramatic walkout
that is a dramatic walk out that's a
nice shot he's a curtain jerker that's a
hell of a guy that guy
so he won silver and men's greco
uh i think it's hard for greco to
translate into mma oh i disagree i
disagree then randy's all up randy and
who else under hope yeah but how hard is
it to get in dan henderson dan henderson
keller another person
if you don't think about it right you
think about it almost all the dagger
standings are all upper body they're all
hip tossed they're all it's like a mix
between judo and greco they do a lot of
okay there's a lot of double a going on
there's a lot but most of them are foot
sweet so can we modify that and say old
school greco didn't translate very well
maybe like a more modified version you
can't say that because you just
mentioned up the two guys dan henderson
and randy yeah but that's older
but once you say freestyle is definitely
more
dominant in what's more relevant it's
more common more people do it it's more
common that's the issue but you can say
that anybody who wrestles on the
international circuit like cejudo and
and uh cormier those guys were exposed
to a lot of greco a lot of like that
yeah
because what it was as soon as you got
done with freestyle as soon as you got
done with collegiate right greco and
freestyle started
programs yeah okay so when you get done
yeah when you wrestle when you get done
wrestling there like you end up doing
like for the summer programs you'll do
like freestyle you also coach kids you
also do greco uh camps as well because
they're trying
to get a lot of people did a lot of that
like knee picks and all that like a lot
of that stuff was up
but that's so yeah but that's all that's
more of a [ __ ] style so [ __ ] judo mix
i guess that sam was influenced more by
greco
aka when habib was there
i was there i was the first one out of
there all right no i'm just saying like
i know you were but
yeah as soon as he as soon as he came in
um i was that was when i was fighting
eight so i was like
he was kind of there i think right he
have a name before he came in did you
guys know like we didn't know who he was
okay so just he came in he was a really
hard worker good kid super nice kid man
he would come in he would train but he
wasn't like he wasn't
some
barn burner like he came in just did his
work like honestly to be honest i got a
call one day from javier i was like hey
man i need you to go corner khabib like
and i think it was in chicago at the
time i was like i was like oh the young
kid that we work with he's like i'm like
i didn't know he's in the freaking ufc
yeah i was like oh yes so you didn't
like blow your hair back no no it wasn't
just that because the wrestling right
yeah he just kind of kept to himself
though too it was really good he was the
first hand that came through super
humble yeah he was the first one first
time saying that came through our gym
yeah yeah boy did open up the flight but
he came he came then he came with uh
with islam and abu bakr they all kind of
came around the same time
oh islam has been there this long yeah i
didn't know that so he came as a
training partner then he came in then he
got into the ufc shortly after khabib
did i know that so i've been told by a
guy from aka that
that habib is
so hard to get out from underneath of
that his top pressure is exquisite and
exquisite exclusive that's a good word
like it's so so good dan fitch dan fitz
told me that if he stands up when he
transmits if he stands up
am i right
and he said if and now john walks around
at [ __ ] 205 yes and he's probably
about 250 yeah
and he and he goes and he said
if i can stand up against khabib
in a practice
it's a good day for me if i can get up
he's like that that's that's john fitch
you have to look i look at the two guys
separately so like khabib has he's got
good top pressure he controls he sits
you back down if you do get up he pretty
much just kind of helped let you up so
he could return you back to the match
it's all about frustration
i have two friends two teammates that
fought him uh michael johnson and abel
trujillo yeah and they both said that
they've they have never
ever felt pressure of when he gets a
gable grip or whatever the hell gable
grip is when he gets this and this yeah
it's over you're right he's in that lock
for the entire round well justin gaichi
said i didn't know how strong he was i
couldn't understand how [ __ ] strong
he felt dude my buddy said that he does
like the rope climbs or something after
practice or something well they just
they just they they'll do their
stretching real quick that guy uh
pitchfork looks like dan frye on camera
yes he does bubba really i thought i
kind of john donald fry wow dance
i said dan because it's his younger
brother that's right that's right you
guys just figured that come on i
honestly think he looks like cubs yeah
cub swanson and he looks like doug
swanson's cubs got the little birthday
uh does madison look like ryan jimmo oh
my friend by the way i broke my hand i
broke my hand on ryan jimmy's forehead
wow did ryan pass away yes he got ran
over and and in a bar in a bar in the
parking lot
yesterday got ran over and killed by a
dump truck and it's getting inspected as
a homicide who did it
investigated as a homicide really yeah
why is like who knows
on purpose but why was it
my question was why was he jogging down
the side of the highway is that what it
was he was driving there's a highway uh
it could have been like a1a a1a is
considered a highway in in south florida
interesting
i mean if you guys need some geography
lessons let me know the don fry look
alike uh trains out of colorado so he
could go for himself so he's got he's
got cardio for days oh yeah um hey how
many gems are there up there other than
trevor's uh oh the high altitude is
there which is like he's about the
stiffest fighter
it's called
but they work together so there's
elevation and high altitude and then
they get together and work together but
then trevor
well you know he has camaro he has
gaichi he has rose so he'll work with
just them and not the other ones but the
other ones all trained together
you know um i went to practice when i
was out to get my black belt and i came
to united to get my black belt and go to
elevation and i was watching the the
just the mat i'm like holy [ __ ] dude
there's some freaking monsters there man
yeah curtis blades out there
corey sandhagen corey santa hagan's
there yeah monsters kamara usman
i got to say this
i love coach henry but marty has gotten
so much more either patient or more
accurate since he went up and saw driver
who's that uh uh
yeah
uh coach henry it's it's you know it's
like those avatar horses when you've got
to find your horse that works with you
and trevor is all about meat and
potatoes basics he doesn't get fancy or
anything so i think for camaro
maybe coach henry's might be a little
advanced especially with his knee issues
like the kicking and the angles and
trevor keeps it really meat and potatoes
yeah i agree with you but i also think
though too there's something to be said
about
coaches that know what they what they
have to offer and they don't bring on
150 fighters they bring on five or six
and they just focus on just those ones
trevor there's something to be said for
the year four right there's something to
be said for rose he's got small he's got
and san hagan right no santa he's uh
christian allen okay
he only works with three so that's what
i'm saying like you you spend you're all
you're doing everything there's a real
full match down there real full matt
down there you know yeah now this guy is
what's his name civil or whatever uh
pitchell he's he's such a stiffer
stiff but he's tough as [ __ ] yeah he's
talking like he watch the way he moves
he's like a lot of women it looks like a
lot of weight on his front foot he's a
favorite yeah he's a minus 115 which i
was surprised but he's from colorado so
makes sense
he's a tough [ __ ] man he just everybody
see you tonight to be tough brian that's
true that's true every single person you
see on this tv i'm just saying i'm just
saying he's a little some of the fans he
doesn't look like he hey brian yeah
you're half iris have italian you'll be
just fine that was nice nice thing
against an olympian that's it that's him
correct he's an olympia but i said he's
a gold medal winner i was wrong he's
selling the middle
officer no joke
so he took down olympian yeah which
means he fought a gold medalist i mean
russell lost to the gold medals yeah
he got a darts
oh what is that and kind of got a roll
right yeah you got a roll did you you
didn't roll me i rolled you did you oh
my gosh look at that why i fell asleep
when i saw him dressed it was so boring
i fell asleep
do you like that that's pretty slick
nice straight punch in my madsen
yeah now mitchell's 39
is he yeah yeah and then he's 30 that's
impressive six 37.
not that's a geriatric fight not some
young chickens here yeah um
how many fights have they had like is
pitchers just kind of starting or is he
has he been here for a while
i don't know i think he's a wily vet
yeah so he's got some good fights to him
that's pitching
um that's mitchell's [ __ ] record yeah
good for him man uh first of all he was
ultimate fighter he's a he's a tough guy
uh well first of all he's only lost
twice [ __ ] twice wow gillespie and
then ruslan wow how
you don't [ __ ] fight enough i know
what's he going through like yeah
he's just i don't know i love when he
fights though he's one of my favorites
he was an olympian he was uh uh i think
he was a olympic wrestler gregory i
don't think so he was craig gillespie
great
check on him check on that i think he
was
brian will surprise you every now and
then i don't think so
i think he josh thompson
[ __ ] monster though i don't think he
was i think ncaa division one champion
yeah i know he was an all-american but i
don't know
is that vince by the way no or is it
pink crazy wrestling pedigree though
look at that no he's a stud not olympian
though you know well hold on keep going
no he's not yeah there it is
division one though yeah i know but
sometimes let me see yeah it was going
to be an olympian right there but
decided not to division one player so
division one national champion though
yeah from that's impressive where dude
national championships
university that's in new york d1 just
national championship
uh
oh so they get some monsters out there
oh yeah they've got some more oh it's a
good that was uh who's uh baumgardner
was their coach oh [ __ ]
coach erickson was my guy
you get some good good coaches oh by the
way josh thompson i have a bone to pick
with you of course i was waiting for
this to be dude
is there beef
let's grill it up this is this is what
the beef is this guy
towards the end of the career
didn't have some good fights and so he's
probably mad at me for that no [ __ ] no
no what are you about to kid me
i have an issue i fought a dude i
absolutely
disdain
big old fat vagrant i fought him in
bellator some about roy nelson and uh
stick and move stick and move a problem
with him i threw all all kinds of low
kicks all kinds of body kicks to him
whooped his ass early took me down a
couple times didn't do [ __ ] when he took
me down yeah
and then the telecast you were like this
dude this dude whatever it's called
was if this dude is running he's running
away from roy nelson because i didn't
stand and trade with him and what's
around and which he said with trout
third round
uh
in the first two he was gassed by the
third round oh for sure in the first the
first two rounds first round and a half
he was sticking the move and thinking i
love what you're doing just game playing
he was doing it again no i get it i
understand that but there was moments
where he had actually you could see roy
sit down like boom got his his knees
kind of buckled a little bit i'm like
throw more like throw one or two more
and then get out you were way faster
than him you knew that but you weren't
like 100 percent you were just throwing
one so join a case
i bet when i bet and i don't know this
for a fact but when you're fighting roy
nelson it was five rounds or three it
was only three three rounds so it's
going to be a 15 minute fight guaranteed
going into it matt knows he's not going
to knock him out fast and nobody knocks
roy out really so i bet matt was like
i'm going to hurt him i got to be
patient experienced don't get enough too
fast yep don't don't don't go for
example don't get over excited if we're
gonna talk about this am i right on that
100 100 in the first 15 seconds i have
him up against the wall and he's shelled
up and i'm throwing i'm throwing fire on
him and i'm like hmm you're about to
catch a nut don't do it so i bail out
this thing what what can i do because
i'd have blown it and that's what he
wants he wants you to blow a knot fast
so he can just kind of absorb and absorb
and then catch you with some blood he's
missing the part where i was saying this
stuff he's kicking him he's hit him with
inside leg kicks outside leg kicks
hitting with a stiff jab throwing one
two landing clean a couple times roy's
leg go go a little wobbly or they go
stiff and he kind of sits down like
hunkers down like i said follow up with
a three and a four and then get out keep
doing what you're doing but you want
more combos i want i want a little bit
more than just one one two one one two
because the thing is when you're talking
about well you were just starting
against the fence that's where you get
clipped that's that's what you're
talking about in the middle of the cage
yeah in the middle of the cage when
you're still moving you hit him a couple
good times where his legs kind of
buckled hit him again add the three add
the four then get out okay because it's
always the third and the four punches i
just understood but you're always afraid
of that right i guess what you're saying
because
you have a history with them so it's
like he's just such i wonder what you're
saying but with with the speed that you
had especially in the first round round
and a half before you got tired you
thought if you would if you would have
thrown the three and a four i'm not
saying you would put them away but there
was a good chance you would at least
sound to his butt or hit him to a knee
which would have definitely won you the
round but you already won the round yeah
as the fight went on you want to make
sure you left that in in the judge's uh
mindset i understand first i i respect
that sounds like we grilled this beef
yeah
we grilled this do i'm smelling what
you're cooking we grilled it we grilled
this people right right now some
scariest [ __ ]
oh by the way so let me tell you this
since we're talking about royale center
people that we fought and knocked him
out carrot town off
yeah keratin off i did not feel any
threat from him whatsoever i didn't
think that he like i wasn't concerned
with him what that wasn't when i had my
mouthpiece falling out a [ __ ] ton of
times
he hit me with a [ __ ] jab
that changed my life
that jab i swear to god i swear to hit
you catch him
right in the middle of the face he hit
me so hard that my whole body went numb
i got a charge to my body and i was like
if you let him see how much that hurt
he's going to kill you i know and like
and like i was like you have to walk
forward you have to jesus like i
couldn't feel my arm and you end up
knocking him out no [ __ ] i got my
escape like he threw my mouth he fell
out for the fourth time
he i walked in i was like i looked on
the ground [ __ ] it threw a straight he
threw hit an uppercut [ __ ] won the
fight he's such a monster yeah he's good
he's he's he's durable um i kick that
dude so many times in the stomach i
thought that his ex
he knocked her out yeah that's why
that's what made me think about the
problem he's a problem problem is that
he's gotten older though he's so slow
yeah absolutely
tough to keep up you know when guys get
this so they get that thick
you're talking about like
he was slow there wasn't i didn't feel
threatened ron desantis right there i
would say this much
he out of my entire career i'm a kicker
right through my entire career that's
happening yeah i never get to sit next
to dana that's wrong rhonda sitting next
to right behind the right there oh yeah
yeah i like ron who's running to santa
who's that uh oh
florida he's awesome hey where do you
live i live in indiana homie what the
hell are you doing here i mean this is
beside the show why can't i just be i'm
just gonna say like why can't one friend
fluently i can't wait
because you were here and i was like i
want to see josh yeah this guy
look you do you do enough podcasts right
someone's gonna have something to say
about it
like for a while it was dc like dc would
get a bunch of [ __ ] from fighters he's
like dude i don't know who the [ __ ] i
never if he's like i'm trying to be cool
yeah but i am no punk man
that's the problem man like in the
position we're in right like you want to
like especially if you have a podcast
that's growing and doing well like in
terms of breaking down fights yeah you
can't make everyone happy you can't do
it do the [ __ ] best you can you also
can't just
like sit down
around because they don't they don't
they don't want they don't come to the
show for that they come to hear the
truth let me express just as honest as i
can
as a fighter you put yourself in a
position of critique right as any
performer right
i will never get my feelings hurt if
somebody says this isn't this unless i
have a disapproving position of it right
like like if i don't agree with it right
now
for example for for josh to be like well
you weren't sticking to moving you you
were running from them right didn't
think you were right and i was like i
want to address it but if you're like at
the end of your career i i have no idea
what you've ever said i've never heard
it yeah but if you're like dude you
mailed it in you haven't been doing [ __ ]
right there's a position on that
i can't say you're wrong now what i will
say
remember i said that
one of my teammates threw a uh
a superman punch and they hit me in the
face and it broke my face and stopped
spawning
because of that
i never sparred after that so i never
got my nut in practice so i never worked
on my lactic threshold other than cardio
oh wow right so so you have to so i
didn't know my my my my position to work
through
and so since i didn't spar i didn't have
that position to be like i know where
i'm at and i can work past it or i can't
uh and so my cardio never got greater
than just training uh training and uh
and cardiovascular work it never got
sparring good and i think that was a
sacrifice i chose to make so i could
keep
my my longevity and my brain now now
what about and i'll show you does that
make sense now what about when you
wrestle though when you wrestle when
you're doing live wrestling i wrestle
that purdue all the damn time yeah that
that'll get you in shape i mean uh but
it's not not sparse yeah but it's not
sponsored
i would tell myself all the time
that uh wow that's so embarrassing he's
getting taken down like that good job
for a dude from
wherever he's from
um
they all call themselves the wolf
i don't know why i don't know three
thousand dollars that look like violence
they call themselves a pit bull probably
jets are very tempting call himself the
wolf yeah his name is very tough really
i've never heard of that yep you see
where chad's
is
amber alert no it's off no it's all
right man hey brian let's just put your
number out there let's see how many
people call so oh dagestand so it
borders dagestan yeah it does yeah but
yeah i i can see why people like dude
he's not from dagestan because he's not
from chechnya
so would you call him chechens that's
where it could be
that's where he's from you speak to
cheney and you're chatting that's the
city your chest that's the city in vegas
see how it borders
famous villain was from georgia
what famous villain in history terrible
man stacey
he's from georgia right there in georgia
not america georgia but right there the
georgia georgia the republic of georgia
uh oh i know this was
it uh
movie villain james bonjour a movie
villain no a real person oh gavin newsom
no
no i like i like where your head's at
like where your head's at
no he's he's he's though he's one of the
worst from georgia oh like it killed a
lot of people yeah a lot of people okay
he's got might might be might be number
one might be the goat joseph stalin is
he really yes
george
i'm [ __ ] impressed with you guys man
like today's a good day no my history he
reads his uh world war ii i read books i
didn't know my geometry i'm glad you
pulled that stuff up
you're getting a cozy look in your face
right now you're getting some whiskey
and you're getting cozy look he's tired
he looks hot in the sun
so we do 23 hours on a flight i'll get
you i go i go next i go three miles
right i do the 5k ladies and gentlemen
matt mitchell is here to take my spot
you you have nothing to prove
athletically so you just walked away
yeah i literally just i was like i'm
done guys i'll see when you guys get
done but when you told me you were i was
like hey you don't have to do all the
obstacles man if you just want to walk
by like when i blew my hamstrings out i
couldn't do certain obstacles yeah
you're like yeah no doubt and then i go
to run up to mark and then everyone's
like oh matt just left yeah i'm done
i say it's not under attack matches for
the rest of the day yeah yeah so they
still do like the one free beer so nice
yeah it's pretty dope that tastes better
than that one of the best tasting
tourist lights i've ever had it was
fresh this [ __ ] was fresh as [ __ ] so
like like the ones you guys said you did
last time where it was freezing i did
one like that too in the rain i got done
i was like this is the most [ __ ]
miserable thing ever it's a horrible
experience
and because you have to do the one where
you go on go in the water yes there's a
cage and you go upstairs now you're in
the water and you're already freezing
because it's soaking wet and then you've
still got doing a cold tub and then we
go mud and we
you climb up but guess what it just
started raining at that time oh so
[ __ ] it was like super slippery so
we're trying to get up we're like [ __ ]
this is [ __ ] slipping and sliding
i'm not trying to do them people were
falling and sliding all the way to the
bottom i was like man what
what's your age 44 are you ready yeah
i'm 43 i'll be 44 this year sexy not a
boy
but i want to let you know
you need to start wearing some deodorant
brother okay you saying i'm funky no no
i'm just simply saying because i put on
deodorant today don't let your wife lie
to you that was your wife
like i was like um wife life's like that
that she just likes that i know i don't
i don't get like i don't get ripe
like but like today i woke up and i said
that's not a good smell yeah i think if
i'm going to be like climbing
you're eating a lot of garlic and [ __ ]
i'm italian yeah yeah
but it keeps never i've never noticed
you smell thank you that's what we get
along really well i'm maybe i'm just
overwhelmed listen i love mckenzie
during hope she gets a win via
submission if we could just fast forward
she was i thought she was uh taller
mackenzie jordan yeah because i saw her
in exeter
the tiny tornado yeah they're both the
same same size how tall
is mackenzie darren i mean she's gotta
be teaching
like five two she's gonna be like
a match
and she was the
competition before me she's tiny five
three he says five four i'd say five
three brandon do grapple at all anymore
yeah do you really yes every now and
then so her and teacher they were
screwed up today face are at the
weigh-ins yesterday they were the same
height
no so yeah so i teach us
maybe we'll see in the case that's itty
bitty five minutes maybe teacher already
put her shoes on who knows by the way
let's talk about something real quick
pokemon pocket monsters
didn't know that until yesterday what do
you mean oh pokemon isn't is a what do
you call it like a shortening oh that's
weird i didn't know that the monster
pokemon pocket monster pocket monsters i
never oh weird yeah that's interesting
it's not a japanese name um josh
thompson if you weren't since it's a
decision right now um are we going to
talk about how umbrella michelle but i
think guy on the right wins probably
yeah what do you think about
michael venom page
uh can you give this answer he's looking
for a title too yeah i can i can give
you the answer he was already scheduled
to fight for the title anyways
bless you no same fight
no no because he's supposed to fight the
russians the russian campaign
is one of the best wrestlers in the game
man [ __ ] style he's still fighting
against ukrainian sorry not russian yeah
jesus
but he's still he's fighting him still
what no no no he's not he he came out
but now they put logan shortly in there
yeah that's why logan stories logan's a
hell of a wrestler yeah he's a hell of a
restaurant remember the two of them the
two of them have one of them wait who's
fighting best fights
logan's playing mvp is he really yeah i
didn't know that i'm so far removed from
the game they're in london he's got to
close that distance otherwise he's going
to get it if he gets to take down on on
mvp he's in a lot of trouble he'll get
him over and over and over but it's a
five-round fight um it's for the interim
title
uh it is
what are we doing yeah well let's let's
address something real quick is that um
it was exposed bellator on probably on
accident expose the fact that mvp is an
extraordinarily extraordinary counter
puncher but he has absolutely zero
offensive strategy when it comes to
stand up well i don't i don't think
bellator i don't think no one exposed
that except for paul daly
said hey yeah i'm gonna wait for you to
come to me and then nothing happened and
then paulie got takedowns and then
that's how he kind of exposed himself
like terrible i don't yeah
is that the fight i'm thinking of i
thought that was another fight paul
daley is still fighting which is
insanity paul daley's got a [ __ ] huge
fight against korshkoff coming up it's
crazy
that's his retirement fight i cannot
shut up
called out paul daley paul they said you
know what coker sent me the [ __ ]
contract next day contractors paul daley
is a bad [ __ ] he is that he's a
bad [ __ ] dude he's fighting
think about him he's 38 39 years old
did you fight him no i tried to i tried
to fight him
they brought me up too there's the dime
they brought me up to
overtime wrestling in chicago to train
with him
and the dude was like right i drove up
there three hours three and a half hours
i'm not training do you remember do you
remember when you couldn't wear condom
depot on your shorts now they're
sponsored by trojans oh trojan got
involved in the game right now wow hey
just a little more money from your
pocket don't worry about it yeah yeah
i'm just
a couple cutie pies by the way a couple
yeah she's she's my i got a little
the very first time she did her
interview and she brought in a
translator like you speak english
i just i lost it i'm like all right now
this is just like inner accents [ __ ]
so let me be honest
i don't [ __ ] why don't i like mckenzie i
don't care if she's riding a russian
transmission let me say this out loud
hey she has she has a cute face she has
the worst ass in them who does mackenzie
get out all right
talk about that against my line
get out let's not talk about girls like
that
let's not do that no because she's gonna
hear that that's mean oh that's not
being mean that's not a that's a great
ass you're out of your mind excuse me
that's a great excuse me man hey matt i
disagree with you you know what it's a
shame you don't know mma i think
somebody else shame on you hold on take
it back right now maybe that was just a
strategy to bring that up maybe come on
you gotta think ahead of the game here
guys okay because like if i said she had
the best ass he would have brought up
that phone
your wife was listening to this and
you're like
she's she's first teammate for sure
she's a killer dude 100 percent and her
dad will choke i'm just trying to think
of the game baby that's all hey listen
you guys have been removed a little too
i've been married a little too come on i
know i just i was like hey careful of
what you say about mackenzie's hey
she's on top of the girl she's like i
knew he was wrong so she's local right
she's she trains
i've heard she's a really cool chick
hershey's really nice no she's so nice i
did i did metamorphosis she's a beast
yeah majority of people that i know that
train at ruka like the facility there
they're all cool cool people
cool people they just pat uh he just has
a good a good knack for finding people
that just are really good people to be
around man
just so it's on the record i was just
kidding mckenzie i think you have a
great time i think you have a great day
here what the [ __ ]
i don't think jerry's mine you know
she's like okay she's really going to
get controversial
everybody's insecure about that look i
don't think she is if you said she has a
flat ass she's like okay she's married
to a grappler or something she's a
fighter i don't know
a surfer yeah
she's gorgeous oh first team man she's
gorgeous yeah
which fight is this why are they showing
this game right now
it's fighting cubs once it's socialized
is this a fight night or something it's
not in this right cub swansea
oh that's that young kid the young uh
korean superstar super boy super boy
josh how many fights did you have
over how many
did you ever fight hook and shoot no no
no okay no no but we uh but a lot of my
fights were i had i had 14 fights before
before sure dog and all these other
websites were around so like they don't
even count those because we were running
rummaging around trying to get video
cameras was there commission
was it commercial missions it was all
like indian reservations it was all like
fairgrounds and [ __ ] yeah like those are
hard to document though yeah yeah so no
one had video footage he's still 14. so
technically i probably i had about i'd
say 14 fights before and then how many
do you officially have a fish you have
30 i think 30
32.
46 fights yeah
like
what made you
say that hey you know what i want to try
this out i don't want to get a real job
i gotta know what college literally
that's what it was yeah exactly i was
like i i started working like in a
cubicle and i'm like
i went from playing soccer wrestling
collegiately you know and then i was
like doing some fights on the side and i
got i got a full-time job working in the
cubicle oh [ __ ] this you want to die i
was like there's just no way you're
insistent i can't spawn i can't spend my
life like this there's no way and i was
making good money i was i was only like
19 20 years 20 years doesn't matter it's
a hell and i was just like and i'm like
i can't do this i think i was making
like at the time 19 years making forty
two thousand forty five thousand i
worked out that's a lot of technology
especially back in the day because
you're 100 years old i mean so do you
making that much money that young
hey out of college i i became a banker i
talked my way into paid you in roman
brothers and i was i was in a cubicle
and i would work and i'd get you wake up
in the dark you put on a coat and suit
and it's high yeah and i did that for 17
18 months and i'm gonna say seven to
eighteen kids oh dude and i remember i
remember i woke up from a nap and i went
i went i woke up and i went if i do this
i'm always i'm going to hate my i
started to hate myself i actually
started making decent money i was making
great money from yeah and that's leaving
a problem but i was like i remember
supporting i remember said if i don't
try to be an actor i think i'm going to
die like i literally was i was like i
think i'd rather die i was starting to
hate myself when did you get in the
comments is this where you say acting
because i i got into comedy because
patty jenkins who was my girlfriend the
time who's a big director
wonder woman never heard of it yeah and
she said to me she literally said to me
hey dummy stop trying to be a brooding
deep actor you're the biggest jackass we
know you make everybody laugh
stand up comedy and i was like i don't
know if i could do it and i and
how old were you then but that's the
thing though 26 bro you got some balls
you have some [ __ ] big balls i need
to step on the stage and do do comedy he
means like saggy baby with you bro
to have that to have that conversation
though be like to sit in him well he now
he started so so when you start when the
way i started was you would start you
have to you'd have bringer shows right
so you'd have to you'd have to bring the
audience almost right
everybody had to have people on their
list yeah in order to get on stage like
five six people otherwise you ain't
getting on yeah
one club owner saw me and liked me
thought i had potential and he would put
me on the opening spot every [ __ ] day
for charlie chaplin yeah
no no at the comic strip thanks a lot
i can see charlie chapman up there going
he was in silent movies bro
he was in silent movies
i'm so proud of you right now i'm so bad
he died in the 70s but anyway i love it
no but
he did die
my mother said to me she said what
happens if this doesn't i still have a
letter that her friend wrote she said
you know unless she's very talented
she said unless she's very talented he's
always going to be a poor
actor and she sent the letter to me my
mother and i kept it and i said i'm
going to [ __ ] keep this letter and
and did you know this lady yeah she
loved me i grew up with her but she was
worried about me but my mother said what
is your backup plan and i said
i don't have one that's the best way i'm
too desperate not to succeed i said that
and i was i was too desperate not backup
plans for [ __ ] quitters it is yes i
had no backup plan i still don't have a
backup you know one of the things i
absolutely love the letter right i love
the one moment
in in every person's life that decided
to say [ __ ] it and give it a whirl yes
right that uh or risk everything yes
there is that one moment that was like i
will remember that for the rest of my
life it's it's called those turning
points yeah and i love you either and
you in those moments you either step
forward or you step back and when i
think about the times that i step
forward it's it's that's why i love my
life but i could have so easily stepped
back man you know just be safe everybody
who loves you is telling you to be safe
it was like thank god that 50 year old
lady wrote that [ __ ] life
i'm telling you because i wouldn't give
a [ __ ]
got me going
look at her she's outstanding
brendan started by i would just put him
out in front of like a thousand people
yeah and he'd come here in chicago and
he'd be like he'd go in and do his navy
seal breathing like he'd be like i see
him in the oh backstage
i still like all right go on out there
just tell a story
that's the big select that's the biggest
thing you're right there's that moment
there for me it wasn't like what one
person said though and what it was it
was the hermes franca fight my second
fight in ufc it was like i got i was
dominating the first two rounds got
dropped i tell the story all the time
with big john on our show like i have to
remind people it's kind of the moment in
your career that kind of let you know
that you belong to be there like you
know was there a moment when you did
comment you're like dudes i [ __ ] i love
this this is perfect for me i love it
like for me fighting was i dominated the
first two rounds against hermes very
first minute he drops me barefoot the
third round in the third round [ __ ]
sits into my face and almost basically
knocks me out i'm like i hit the ground
i woke back up and started fighting next
two and a half minutes he beat the [ __ ]
out of me like [ __ ] ref almost
stopped it do you remember it larry
lannister i remember every [ __ ]
second of it but you want to fight but i
but at the end of that [ __ ] third
round with a minute left he had gassed
himself out on my face i was able to
[ __ ] scramble get back on top and i
finished around on top and on my feet
and that to me at the end that was that
moment where you're like this is it i
was meant for this i was cut out for
this
i feel like sports like wrestling i
could have found a way out like
wrestling changed my fabric let
wrestling change my dna i think as a
young as a boy i make my son wrestle
yeah and my middle son my oldest son
loves to wrestle yeah my middle son
[ __ ] hates it but i make him do it
because
it's such a miserable sport that it
forces you to understand work dudes i
know your time might take a long time it
forces you to understand uh
that i don't want to but i have to yes
uh yes and and wrestling yourself come
easy for anybody
but that's why i think i think my
favorite people are wrestlers i'll tell
you this much i think that the greatest
thing in the world can happen the great
thing america can happen is everybody
has to play a team sport for like three
four years that's terrible and i think i
think wrestling is really important
wrestling teaches you tenacity and [ __ ]
it let's go it does i think if desantis
becomes president he either makes guys
wrestle for four years in high school or
you have to enlist in the military
something either or let me ask you this
so is he is he running with uh trump and
him together i think there's no way
there's no way it should be that he's
running out no i don't agree i think
he's gonna endorse uh desantis i don't
think trump's gonna
think so no it's too polarizing i think
he knows it like it creates chaos yeah
but he'll be trump's gonna be the king
maker but he's not gonna because he goes
so big though i wouldn't be surprised
see i i might this is what i think is
gonna happen it's trouble i think
trump's gonna run with december's vp
because he can only run for four years
so he'll step away and desantis will
take over for the next eight
because he'll be dude he's getting worse
than we got now
um i i just feel like that's right i
feel like trump is so polarizing that we
will that the uh conservatives
conservatives not republicans
i like it she's she's she's shredded
she's a fan she's yeah i'm a girl i like
a girl
i like a girl with traps who's your wife
what's your wife's name
uh i don't i think you're thinking of
somebody else yeah it's for kel
pennington yeah no but it's her that
recovery
oh i didn't know that's like her wife is
a gangster too they were she fought
earlier yes did she win
are they somewhere
number four what's up they're still
married i don't oh i'm sorry but but i
think but i think they're still they're
very close okay i know they're very
close dude pennington is a gangster too
man wait wait is mackenzie during half
brazilian is that what her dad's
megatron dude okay i'm sorry megaton
megaton or megatron what city you're
from it's okay no it depends what city
you're here it depends on where you're
sitting here
yeah she's mad pretty
that's her dad right there legend i
gotta take this piss you gonna take a
[ __ ]
kayla you're not alone
yeah she couldn't help but be a jiu
jitsu wizard yeah
literally you can't help at it maybe
yeah dude
she's mad awesome
you know what's weird to me man it's
weird to me that pretty girls fight
like i would imagine it'd be the chicks
from from crybaby that fight that'd be
it yeah like they're the ones they're
the feminists they're the they're the
forefront they're they're changing like
men's minds on what's possible they
don't get any credit can i can i ask a
question about this yeah did you see
obviously you did dave chappelle when he
was talking about
like trans yeah no no no no uh he was
talking about something about women and
he was like listen dude like there's
you can't yeah i think it might have
been and he's like listen you can't get
salty about it you guys said you were
equal
[ __ ] chill out that's a fascinating
position can they especially broadcast
from that from that
platform or that podium
like like leah thomas right
[ __ ] 450 best swimmer best swimmer
and all of a sudden now you're number
one
now it takes all american status away
from women who worked their whole lives
take scholarship [ __ ] twitter blocked
her twitter the chick you guy who like
got bumped out of the finals because
they hit and she started ramping off and
they blocked her yeah that's why
that's why elaine but
elon musk i almost called milan bust
elon musk uh bought all that stuff
because now he's gonna be on the board
and that's why so many people have
freaked out freaked out and quit good
because now he's gonna really and all
three you have trump back you have that
poor girl who got banned so scientists
who said it was the chinese virus came
out of a lab it's not misinformation at
this point we know that and they're like
a senator marcia blackburn didn't she
didn't she like blanders i didn't know
that girl got [ __ ] banned on twitter
that's outrageous i also didn't know
that if you're saying so leah thomas
said so i'll just just you could put on
a wig and get into weightlifting right
now
if you don't if you don't go along with
their agenda you're you're getting a lot
of green too you can't have freedom
because because they believe in tyranny
and censorship oh think about you want
to talk about misinformation about all
the misinformation they they think about
the legit information they blocked from
getting the right because they didn't
do as chris says don't [ __ ] push me
dude don't push me over am i right on
the right probably
chris is in irvine tonight
he might be in irvine but i'll tell you
something right now guys oh i'm glad you
said that i'm in arizona stand up live
next thursday friday saturday then the
week after i'm in uh nope i got you a
moon tower comedy festival your boy
changed dates your boy's coming up i'm
at the paramount theater now one night
only saturday okay no more cap cities
they moved your boy up to the freaking
paramount theater in austin texas well
you know what i'm going to connect with
you in austin
oh yeah come through let me open for you
let me tell some jokes come on down to
tampa this weekend it's coming weekend
he's not doing it
you know friday saturday and then i got
pregnant charlotte the sonic comedy
theater las vegas nevada wise guys
comedy club april 28th to the 30th and
then i got the stress factory in new
jersey
we're going to shoot you
so come see me in the stress factory i
can't wait to do that club have you done
that club stress factor
i'm supposed to do it and then something
happened one of the best
oh look at her his daughter
that's her husband hell
yeah i could grow an afro i would grow
the [ __ ] out of an afro
feel like you could you got good hair
though
because you know why don't you look good
here for the size of his hands
massive yeah
uh you want to bet mckenzie via
submission
uh now mackenzie anybody any takers they
aren't really the same the same height
uh you know what i don't know enough
about
this
little tornado you know what's awesome
about both of these have such muscular
legs
yes i love it dude like that like i love
the fact when people have like a an
equally distributed like uh muscularity
i think it's fantastic i don't have
technology
her movement's so damn good
she's like you're like your little
mighty mouse thing
uh is that is that is that submission
game too hard to deal with
oh it's the best in strawweight probably
ever
being it's probably the best in the
female division
by far well
there's that one [ __ ] badass at 135.
girl uh female yeah what are these guys
at 125 right now or 115.
115. 115. yeah wow tiny not called the
tiny tornado she was at 135. she's
looked so much like she's leaned out so
much more since she had her baby ken's
journey yeah isn't that amazing yeah
i got so much flack i did rogan show a
while back and i talked about how
females is they hit like
30 like 30 31 32 or whatever it is yeah
they get a little bit older they start
their bodies change and they feel out
like a lot better in terms of they start
slendering out oh gotcha
you got heat from that yeah i got heat
from them
really
they they
it's like when they're younger they
still have like a little bit of that
i don't say baby fat sure but as they
get older they start everything fills
out they start maturing it just looks
like you might get a little more hate
now um of course
hey chen who am i thinking of is it
marina roberts
yeah she's a striker savage yeah she's
good too
i think mckenzie's better
pure jiu jitsu yeah
i think that's what i'm thinking of it
might be amanda too
teacher torres is
giving her the business i was gonna say
do you how strong do you think torres is
for her size do you think she's got just
crazy strength oh yeah
because she looks like just such a pops
you know crazy muscular
i mean
it's good
i'm surprised uh mckenzie jordan doesn't
jump to half guard on her she's that
good on the ground did you watch the
olynyk fight
he literally like just pulled the other
guy on top of him and then caught him
not joking he got the the yeah
yes yeah yep so then he pulled him on
top then was able to work through he
worked to the ex-car he came out the
back door swept shut up scrambled on top
trying to get on top couldn't get on top
kemp on the single leg got reversed the
position
the other guy had his back for a second
and then got back and he resisted out of
there got back on top passing got right
to his back choked him yeah all within
dude do you think
he is
is that true yeah he's got a dick on him
oh the dick started what a stun
congratulations
i got to meet him
that's why he moves
what
and then just gets annihilated well dude
it sucks like dude it's massaging man
one of those people
he's the ageless wonder man
yeah if you don't give him the credit oh
well dude when he won that fight i
touched wrong i go dude if i can make
one match up if the ufc said all right
job you freaking [ __ ] sucker what what
fight would you wants to do besides jon
jones francis or john jones stipe i'd go
dude i want izzy versus gegard musasi oh
i want you to reach out and i want to
scott coker i would love to because
it's kickboxing it's the one argument
that that bellator can make hey we have
the best middleweight in the world
because i think it it like i always say
if aliens came to earth they're like all
right we're going to watch one guy for
to represent mma who is it i would say
it's izzy
kenzie turn is is catching her guard
over him
better way better submissions and when
he hits the ground guards has a good
chance and he looks like he doesn't get
a heavy big energy in the hips he's
striking his strike
is i know what i'm saying though is if
if gagar gets into the ground it's
always easier said than done though it
is you're trying to said that but is
he's not getting this you're 240 pounds
yawn block of [ __ ] you ain't getting
them down yeah so get them down i
understand i think i can get him down
gengar's got a lot of tricks up his
sleeves i'm a huge fan of massache and
i'll put that out there
but i will say
if he didn't fight
um
his homie his really good friend
brazilian dude great grappler jackaray
oh well
this is a small cage
took him like like really like just
putting him in the guilty because
quickly but it's because he could in my
opinion there's a small cage didn't have
as much gay guard
i'm the biggest gay i'm not throwing
chamomile lost to your eye hall though
did he really yeah everyone has those
days everybody you fight guys that are
on your level hey don't show up he
hasn't yeah i agree i agree yeah is he
also he's fighting monsters tell me how
many from me yeah that's the greatest
the motivation yeah but the motivation
level though
is he still fighting you know top
caliber guys i get i don't know i get
what you're saying but look he's waiting
for him
he's not disenfranchised he's not just
branch out yet what i'm saying though is
that with gay guard he's 60 fights in
you've got to fight guys that motivate
you yeah yeah there's come there comes a
level where you got to fight guys
and i break your interest i think that's
what happened with john jones too yeah i
like you 100 how does john jones have
the end of it fantastic i think he'll do
great i've seen what he does the
heavyweights personally
is gay guard um still fighting at the
top of his game he's the yeah i think
right now i think he's the real champion
yeah and you think yeah you think he's
actually you know what here we're gonna
we're gonna have a telltale situation
here because i mean the because what's
gonna happen is he's gonna fight uh
johnny evelyn which i think i think he's
got a good chance of beating johnny
because johnny's 11 and 11 0 or 10 or
whatever like like austin was okay and
they're training partners all that being
said oh oh she bull guard [ __ ] there you
go uh-oh here we go oh oh i don't know
dude she just push on the hips and get
away now what do you do here what do you
do she's gonna try dragging her down she
but notice how she's securing the arm
before she goes down she's gonna wrap
her little arm around her neck
and she's her head's high too right now
oh she's going for a camera baby she's
gonna start attacking that arm oh oh and
she's gonna get it and go to the ground
and she's gonna snap it off like chicken
wing oh oh no what do you do what are
you doing here what do you do you gotta
stay right there again right there
stay right there no she can't she can't
submit her triceps
i'm very happy with that she just did a
fitness competition did you really yeah
follow her that's fantastic
she showed up because that's right i'll
follow her who has more definition go uh
she looked she went oh god
this is gonna be a screenshot forever
brian brian oh
turn your back to the cage what do you
do here you gotta go back to the cage
oh that was nice when she pushed off the
cage though oh my god i can't be pushed
off the cage that's like a brazilian
koala she's a koala she's like dude she
got oh oh it's over it's over oh my god
twerking oh
it's so over yes step over there
she's gotta step over three minutes of
this three minutes of this though on the
ground three minutes it's not good
no way i'll show you oh yeah she got
something
there what grateful hormone partner no
no
it's gonna be beautiful see you gotta
stay on top oh oh you know what oh my
god
you know what oh my god she's a bad
[ __ ] oh get away good job get
away get away get away
what are you doing get away come on
t-shirt
her leg is stuck hold on let me talk to
her like we practice t-shirt throw your
breath no put your arms throw your
breathing keep putting keep your arms
out of there please arm in there keep
your arms out of there please
oh t-shirt oh it's not damn it mckenzie
it's the wrong arm but yes arm so good
though i mean hey chris idle hits an
inverted arm bar like that with it with
your with your near arm dude it is one
of the most uncomfortable things i've
ever had now what do you do you stay
stacked you you trap that arm the way
she is right there
no you want to stop she's it i'm just
sitting on her arms
sit on it so she can't use that hand
anymore yeah the glove gets stuck who's
he's spending more energy right now
they're right kenzie mckenzie is yeah
because all of her weight's on top of
now and she's nervous about her arm
being stuck she's gonna rock she's gonna
end up in mount i bet you it's so crazy
she just sits there waiting
keep her stack keep her knee right by
her [ __ ] ear just like we talked
about that's it t-shirt josh you guys
got to leave the table i have to talk
what is your favorite fight you ever had
was it hermes franco fight that one it
was that's right up there with the top
of them yeah um was it nick oh oh oh no
no no no probably like
you just
went into frightening did you know
you're did you know you're gonna be my
favorite my favorite fight was the
second guild fight even though i came up
short on that it was honestly when you
go back and watch that fight it was just
a fun fun fight dude mckenzie's legs
would be pretty toasty at this point he
got after it threw down it was awesome
she does this in her diaper look at this
look at this
what is going on here well hopefully the
refs are giving mckenzie yeah no now you
want to just you want a moment she wants
to keep her head down oh oh oh we going
for ankles baby oh jesus
she's so good hold that arm oh dude it's
where the world run down there got to me
you can't trade
oh i'm getting brisket yeah it's over uh
oh
she's oh she's got it locked in
oh baby oh
dude that [ __ ] put your arm off trying
to go to hold push your arm off instead
of trying to go to hold on enjoy 40
seconds 40 seconds 40 seconds
40 seconds
ah that's a little tornado
oh my god
that was so dramatic right there dude
that whole series oh she's cranking that
ankle that hurts no there's not there's
not pressure on it yet right let me do
that to your ankle all right oh [ __ ]
this man this is bad for her ankle i
don't like this
i don't like ankle [ __ ] is she going to
be all right 22 seconds she had 22
seconds
mckinsey is going to go hard for like
the last 10.
oh she really let it go yeah
elbow in the face yeah she's going to
sit there what around though dude
see how she gets up oh she's fine oh
she's going to help her up beast dude
she's like
that's really impressive [ __ ] a
you guys think women can't fight [ __ ]
you guys you're showing us
sorry guys
i mean
i love you
patreon dancing uh she's doing this
wwe right now
she should have been doing that she
should have been doing that
yeah she should have been writing
ufc too though you know like you know
well i'm not saying she wasn't a good
fighter i'm just saying like for for her
personality for everything that she has
she should have been wrestling the whole
time well but i think she needed the
platform from the ufc platform yeah
oh you're not some great advice like
you're fighting against
yeah of course
a little nervous
uh i'm sorry guys i was interrupted
sorry sorry sorry oops huh sorry
but um
yeah but remember her fight against
michelle waterson when she remembered
she did the jump kick and then went on
dancing with the star i think she danced
with stars won that then came back did
the jump kick
she's going sizzler man yeah and you
know she has she has not she didn't do
only fans she launched her own thing
like her own business really dude you
know she made it bro good for her dude
i've heard i've heard i've heard
rumblings of i don't know what she makes
yeah so we're talking yeah oh we don't
have to do anything real real good yeah
dude i did not subscribe to it i want
you here we go
i've never seen those fantastic pictures
i really appreciate the fact that her
and her husband austin
understand the position
like there's a certain amount of like
you get so much hate dude
he has nothing to prove good for him
good for him
he's a badass she could say i guess
what's the name it's a dog you know what
it is it's a lot of kids or not oh she's
like kids a lot of grown men in their
basement who can't get girls
so they're knock on hers like oh you
don't win it's like yeah you know she
makes them
over a million dollars knocking punch in
the face yeah
have a good she's already one dumb she
wants yeah she won the game
looks like that yeah yeah and i don't
think they'd be saying that to austin's
face either so they should shut the [ __ ]
up and yeah one guy in the bow tie
yeah guarantee that guy's subscribed
server he's already he's he's making
good money too i mean nothing wrong yeah
he's not he's not he's not he's not paid
money but still yeah but he's still
making i mean yeah she makes it taking
pictures they're doing just but yeah he
did so austin lost his last fight yeah
that was this is a gay guy dude
such a good wrestler dude he's a great
wrestler and i'll be honest with you i
really enjoy him as a person he's a
really really i've had paige on food
trucking numerous times he always comes
yeah he's such a nice he's so cool dude
yeah and like a tattoo on his right hand
you know what else i really enjoy too i
love the fact that he's not he's he's
not such a douche he can't
clown himself by calling himself mr van
zandt yeah so what he's like i respect
the [ __ ] out of that hey dude
that's why i kind of wanted to win that
fight even though gay guards were my top
five phase of all time i just wanted to
get out of that shadow of because if
you're worried about world championships
you can't we can't call you mr van
zanden
i've heard that uh um gegard is
independently wealthy like for his has
invested his money so so well
financially you didn't see the last
promo he did on him no he owns like a a
village yeah
it's up on the top of this mountain
where he owns a house here and he built
a house in the same driveway for his mom
him
there's conversations you gonna fight
the winner of the light heavyweight uh
uh uh uh so him versus either corey oh
oh oh up kick cool oh whoa
oh she's watching she grabbed the fence
torres is a bad [ __ ] man this is
the time for the uppercut oh batkin are
you kidding me tiny tornado dude did she
drop her what happened she she kicked
her in the face kicked her dropped
mckenzie took her down then she [ __ ]
kicked her right in the face brennan at
any time in your career did you grab the
fence to stop a takedown never i think i
did once really once just once
i think it was on kimbo i was like my
second fight and kimbo
i think t-shirt is going to win this
fight that's when you know i have no
take down defense yeah when kimbo
shooting you're getting the fence yeah
by the way i think that knee kick should
be nice uh yeah i hate those knee kicks
i think it also works though the kids
got to get a takedown man
or or just get in tight and jump to
guard again because she was in a lot of
trouble she almost finished her there i
don't know if she if that worked in the
last she won the scene she won she won
the second she was there for sure no
doubt yeah
what about the first round no no
this is it's coming down
it's coming down this [ __ ] round oh
oh
oh these girls are bad they are banging
man i think two oh [ __ ]
mackenzie during this oh oh [ __ ] is that
kind of stupid
go down there go down let me know you
got money on this fight i want to
i'm a big mckenzie durham fan
i'm i'm both i'm fans of both you got to
pick one
come on man don't make me pick but
you're clearly going for the tiny
tournament i want to date but i'm fine
with that
dinner's ready girls she's doing so good
and just slipping out of the way and
coming out the backside yeah
you gotta jump for a leg yeah do
something because striking ain't it girl
damn dude she's kicking those legs hey
diver tell you about the time there was
a six foot five chick that was training
in our gym down in south florida did you
have to put her down dude she kicked me
so [ __ ] hard in the face was she from
amsterdam uh she was she's from russia
did she kick me so hard i swear to god i
was i was
i was i was i was stumbling effectively
what did you do
i was like [ __ ] i'm kicking her now
yeah i i had to get through if you're
gonna kick me like a dude i've got and
she's rushing dude i was like so i
started laying into her legs i think i
had to man i told this story all the
time i had drain germaine duronamy
she came in on my fifth round i did like
two rounds with khabib two rounds with
with fitch and she came in in the fifth
round she threw her spinning back kick
right to my face look at this look at
this i was like what the [ __ ] it landed
it landed yeah atlanta right flashing my
face
oh as a fight took her down
i don't know about that i don't know i
don't know
take that that takedown didn't win right
right who won i'm giving that to
t-shirts yeah yeah
i'm giving that two strokes god their
kid is super who is that who's that guy
that's his that's her husband's husband
it's your friend
he's a surfer good for him
good friend that's right she's a badass
but i think i think t-shirt has won that
fight that's good
who won the first round this was nuts
this was nuts that's the closest to
finishing the fight tisa won the second
time
you give that a 10 eight rounds did you
give that a 10 eight rounds
it was going in
the third rally and she won the third
round
but they'll give it to mckenzie
the judge as well i can't i don't think
you can give it a ten eight round
i don't know i was just not exaggerating
all right because i want mackenzie to
win a little kick to the face this is
where this is the kick that oh gosh oh
that was in the throat chest oh she was
at wobble she's got hit right in the
[ __ ] throat she's offensive oh she oh
she's fine i thought she was wobbled oh
i don't know man i could see him give it
to mckenzie i thought she was wobbled
there t-shirt won that whole third round
i think the home crowd's playing hard i
think t-shirt no no bias here no bias
here all right no bias here she won
though t-shirt won that that third round
dodgers win
uh controlling 1-1 going into the uh i
think the fourth
third or fourth
so is in california
la's a complete dodger tone yeah no you
won't find an angels fan here because
like
illinois indiana-ish not here orange
counties kind of far from here so
they're angels fans and then also
listen i like to use craving to fire up
my brain matt matrione before any of my
show stand up podcast whatever it is
it's my secret limitless pill you want
to be like bradley cooper in that movie
yeah yeah yeah dude the happy hippo
kratom though i'm dude i'm glad you said
it because the best product i've ever
used i use it for the tough mudder today
and your boy was a move-in now i wish i
used sunscreen okay because my face is
beat red but do you have a promo code
like if i wanted to get happy hip-hop
yeah you read it brian's always messing
it up
visit abbyhippo herbals.com and use
promo code thick boy that's with three
c's for twenty percent off for life oh
they gave it to yeah man get happy hippo
using dickboy uh for 20 out for life for
promo code visit happyhippo herbals.com
and also mckenzie during one i [ __ ]
told you
i must have missed something in the
first round i must miss him too you guys
must not know the fight game no because
your boy called him no i just don't see
it
she's also right there good chance yeah
she's undefeated
yeah oh my gosh hey don't go ahead and
say this it'd be really hard to fight
with my father as a corner
like whether my father's accomplishing
that my dad was like tough butter today
how about my dad gets a wooden stick
while i'm going through the lecture
thing goes remember all the [ __ ] you
were talking and goes to push the
electric yummy wow and they were filming
their i go down i'm telling you if you
elec because i i [ __ ] hate being
electric when i'm in water you're so bad
told me that i'm like i'm gonna get out
we're gonna fight i swear to god i'm
gonna get you
might beat me i don't give a [ __ ] we're
going to fight here's all
so i did what i did when i did one of
the tough mudders they had i was they
had the tables that hang down right yeah
you got to crawl through the mud on the
bottom like that
and i was like crawling through the mud
and i was like i think start it all i
started off standing i was like oh i'm
good i'm good so one hit me i was like i
feel like i was in a movie dropped to
one knee hit one's at me again dropped
the other knee it's hitting me again
dropped down on my [ __ ] i was in the
army crawling they said i wake up got
[ __ ] mud in my eye couldn't get it
out
at the end they have that
electric like that see i wanted to just
do this yeah electrocution where you got
to run through yeah hayes and stuff yeah
i remember last time yeah to finish you
gotta run through electric therapy yeah
i'm fine i'm fine one long one i see it
going like this it goes
boom right in the middle of the forehead
whole body goes
yep i was going to do that actually i
was going to run through it with you
guys
he looks like he's about to fight but i
kind of felt like it wasn't really my
place because i didn't do the rest of it
so now you should just kind of go
is that the cutest little kid in the
world that's her that kid right
adorable
her her husband is so excited he can't
even stand good but imagine a [ __ ]
wife i've never seen her like that in my
life
it would be so hard to have your
boyfriend
the cutest kid in the [ __ ] world oh
my god
what are we doing how can you not root
for that girl you guys are pieces of
[ __ ] really you two little girls cage
side with with her dad and you're
rooting against her i'm just saying wow
you know what though goodwin goodwin
maybe maybe jim ross looks young
tony con co-owner
pedro beast he is a beast man
he's got big power oh here we go
oh [ __ ]
matt
would you like to bet on this fight
gilbert your boy hamzlot's my
sibling do we have do we have odds what
do we have odds there's no odds i mean
that's like
look at how relaxed he is
that's that's right that's
take that gilbert makes it through the
first round you know what
i'm going to say something i don't like
the way that you you're a huckleberry i
bet you're a grand i agree we're relaxed
here wait hold on a minute here we have
odds we have odds we can't just throw
the options go go go go through that
harms out get the uh go to
draftkings.com use promo code shop if
you if you go to draftkings they will
have problem coachup if you go to
draftkings and see homs odds to get a
finish in uh i bet it's like minus one
and a half
hey but gilbert brown comes out to
finish his mine is minus one and a half
do you think that's all it is he's a
seven hundred no no seven one no ham
dots minus five ten hold on but let me
see these odds uh comes up by win humps
that win win win they don't have it by
rounds so hamza to win uh by ko is plus
plus 110. here's the rounds hamzat
to win by sacraments plus 350 dude so
what are you so if i bet 100 bucks
i win 350. what you said by the first
round so first round is plus 130. so
they're saying that the odds are
wins by first first round plus 130. what
are you saying what do you what do you
think
i have literally the worst record ever
all right let me bet him no i'm gonna
bet you i'll bet you how about this if
we're gonna do a grand yeah
i'd rather do two two grand for second
round under okay all right so so hold on
second round under means that's not all
right hold on hold on no if he goes past
the second round he wins the money if
hamzah wins first second round i win the
money that does two grand i'll be back
i think gilbert burns is not easy he's
not you're not gonna see yeah but that
doesn't make any sense if he makes it
through the two rounds yeah he just
hustled you you wait what what did you
say what no it should have been around
in half or around for like first the
first one
two minutes
if it goes through a round even if hamza
wins by decision in the third round
i understand but that's gonna go to the
third round gilbert is no [ __ ] joke
and i i think that comes that's going to
wrestle him but i don't know if you
finished gilbert you're not you're not
finishing it he's calling conquest
what the [ __ ] is that brian let me just
address this yeah brenda and i were just
negotiating the first round and then
we're like if it goes to the second
round i get this like the game the
game's over yes and you just gave him
the entire second round for more money
for one and a half rounds
no we did no hold on too late that was
very sure
two rounds two rounds earlier your boy
wins i'm just telling you i think he's
done the first round i think i'm about
that much of a [ __ ] demon jesus but i
could be i could be wrong for me the
verdict's not out for me yet i want to
see more i want to see him go through
some sort of adversity
i want to see if he can i know look we
all know he's the hammer
how is he when he's the neo the justin
i love gilbert i've i've never met hamza
i know gilbert is a fantastic human
being yeah i want would there be any
shade on gilbert all i'm saying hamza
colby count on abc you don't want to see
that i do that's what i do that is the
one that i wanted
i want to see comes out against
is he out of sonia after he fights
after
he's so crazy dude he if he really put
on gun in weight room he couldn't even
find that light heavyweight oh my god i
think he'd be a three division champion
wow
no i i i'm not saying he can be dizzy
let's see how he does against gilbert
all right and then ask me that yeah
because i'm with you you gotta go
against colby and he's gonna win
after correct those guys can wrestle
yeah but you know i agree that he's
wrestling yeah
yeah yeah
yeah he wrestles he wrestles
in practice olympic gold olympia
alvin
gilbert
he was an international level wrestler
hey challenge who did he compete against
in the underground submission
uh come on bro jackson did you see what
i
did
but he also was not he was also not 70
when he fought him gilbert gets him
against the wall hamza is in trouble uh
no no hamza hamzat is very comfortable
very comfortable on the client he's just
so much better what are you getting from
the buffet yeah please
i'm so lightheaded hey i've had no lie
400 calories today
well there's probably about
30
no sugar in this no sugar it's good man
tiger thick of it in 40 states now man
hey listen to yourself
takes this fight lightly though he seems
like he's really relaxed no that he hold
up hold up
oh you're a newbie oh you're newbies hey
welcome to the train i'm the conductor
for the hamsa train okay welcome to the
trailer
excuse me i'm you're the doctor no i'm
welcome no i'm not stupid no you're
putting the coil in the machine no
no you're putting the coil in [ __ ] that
i'm going
i was on his dick way early no sir he's
always chill though i mean you didn't
know that trying to tell me i know you
didn't know that he's talking while he's
[ __ ] doing [ __ ] i know he's chill i
just get a little nervous because
because gilbert burns is very explosive
ver i don't think he's fought anybody as
explosive at least not
that that i can think of
gilbert burns is very explosive you're a
good man
big mike might give it to me look at him
against the wall i think there's trouble
brian has two quarters on it i got two
grand and you all said you're on the
hamza train you're get the [ __ ] i like
making things exciting
i like making things exciting look at it
relax man that's how i walk dude
let's go brian we gotta start training
do you know why he's so relaxed because
you know he's about to [ __ ] them up did
you hear the story on him
which one i guess apparently he got in
trouble when he was younger
some kid like beat him up or something
like that right when he was younger
and then he came home
and his dad said something to him and
said like why'd you let him do it you
failed you failed and the kid said and
then hamza said
fine i get the gun i go i take care of
him right now i kill him and his
brother's like no no no no like he'll
basically take this fight he'll go all
the way to the very end is i think what
the metaphor they were trying to use
he'll take this [ __ ] all the way to the
very end he don't care that's how much
you heard what he's about to do to uh
conor mcgregor yeah no he got arrested
by the
by the police in dublin hamza before he
was even in the ufc connor was so
disrespectful to khabib and muslim
anything dude he bought a ticket from
sweden
flew to dublin just to walk into conor
mcgregor's gym and [ __ ] him up but word
got out that he was flying in there and
they arrest him at the airport and spent
like a day in jail and we're like you
can't do this they sent it back yeah
look at that
wow
dude
dude he
name a bigger uh name a bigger prospect
than hamzad go
don't say patty pembleton i love patty
no i think so i'm not even on the same
train as that people are on that train
i'm like he he's like a slow play and
they're gonna slow play
for sure at 55 for sure yeah
he's gonna be a khabib we're gonna have
to have like
15 fights before your title shot kind of
thing you know
can we some more barbecue sauce on there
stat
of course i'm happy with what we're
doing right now that barbecue sauce is
house oh that barbecue this is from
burbank barbecue mike
what'd you say
handy market
take a little spice too break off a
piece then you know who knows barbecue
is matt matrione oh man he does yeah
meathead knows me i'm gonna like you
guys how are you what are you at you're
you're you have no no fat on your body
you've been taking care of it you've
been eating well um you keep saying that
listen yeah you know you keep saying
that all i'm saying a little bit is that
when it comes down to meat meat knows
i'm part of the uh i get down i go hard
barbecue smokers i know about stuff like
that i know about meat i'm ready for
that game know about some some
seasonings
oh man it's nice huh a little something
a little buzzing that's nice right there
for you guys
thank you
i hate to eat on there i have to do it
i'm sorry for those listening hopefully
nobody's chewing in the mic nobody's
chewing on mike
unfortunately something
amazing happened terrible terrible
happens yeah and you die
who narrates your
biography
probably forget it man it's coming back
she's grappled yeah she's coming back
yeah we're the our weighing in podcast
is hosting the channel jones by the way
are you a comedian
cause you said when you're a kid you to
be an actor yeah so we're going to be
there doing that so big john and i are
hosting the the president for bellators
yeah on monday nice dude
oh this guy
oh my you're just sitting on the cage
right now gangster if you were offered
you gotta be careful now seriously
yourself
would you be like [ __ ] yes like jim
carrey and justin
right
internal sunshine you see guys like that
they fall in love with them by the way
do you like your tournament no i think
it's one of the best movies
i love you right we have a great
relationship you're a good friend of
mine thank you hey listen thank you if
i'm never going to talk about eternal
sunshine and you bring up [ __ ] sonic
the hedgehog well
i'll kind of agree with you well hold on
it's the last movie he did matt it's not
going to happen and now he's retired
from acting you understand me unless
something amazing
listen you will not
you will not disrespect
[ __ ] eternal sunshine with sonic the
hedgehog that's fair
but i like the truman show better
internal sunshine
the door's over there hey hey brandon
can i read the name you said i randy
dern
i said that just to get her upstairs get
her pulled up hey and absolutely not you
can't because you saw the walkouts
let me let me let me okay let me pull
back on my bedroom this is i don't like
gilbert burns looks like he's really not
happy to be there hey do you guys have
salt
absolutely not
i'm not i'm assault i'm a salt [ __ ]
gilbert doesn't look happy
that's nice that's really good he's
always uh stressed out well he's he's
yeah there's a lot of pressure
on him right nobody wanted to fight homs
no how much how much does he drop that's
just
how much do you drop in the rankings if
he loses because he's not even ranked
11 but he's on the top 10 a man
dropping right now i don't want to
change it yeah no absolutely not no hey
go down for a thousand dollars cut it in
half and a half
you gotta hold his feet to the fire he
also was like i'm the hamza train after
you bet two grand again i'm on the
homicide i gotta teach them i like to
get a little crazy but now i just saw
that so i work out walk out and i'm a
little worried now god hey how long
before we see a theo van tree like damn
dana i can't believe you gave us this
one for only 80 bucks you're too good to
us
hashtag ufc 273. he tries to get on
every single broadcast
heads has comes out heart says burns
otherwise fight is giving you chills
yeah
dude
i believe that hamza truly believes that
destiny is on his side look at him
look at him oh my god he's scary he's
the boogie man of the [ __ ] ufc he's
from chicago
i'm nervous as [ __ ] right now i like
these guys right like with with khabib
he had over 250 uh [ __ ] matches like
you think he really cares about the 20
fights or 30 fights he's had 29 and no
like it's like he's already 250 times
that's what he does those are real life
fights
that's a huge gilbert burns is not 510
either i think he's probably closer to
five eight is that true yeah he's
probably about he is not five ten and
every bit of six two five five
comes out
he's thick
i don't know if i would wear all black
underneath that suit if i'm bruce there
i'm gonna go ahead and tell you guys
this my favorite story bruce buffer
that's when he tore his acl introducing
gsp
uh at the pool in las vegas no no he was
introducing gsb at ufc 129 was it in
toronto he did a jump or montreal 360.
he tore his acl i know he blew his knee
out too doing like a spring break like
ufc did he really yeah i didn't know
that that's
awesome he's just so passionate you know
dude i love him oh he's the best
call him uncle bruce
you're still nervous you're always
nervous huh you guys have all been in
there it's always i don't care you think
they're both nervous as [ __ ] regardless
and it's alarming
i'll tell you what i wouldn't be feeling
good right now if i bet two grand
against that savage hey you're a good
bet come back
thanks buddy thank you you did say when
we were riding a tough mudder today a
nice hour and a half drive you went pipe
down about gilbert burns how he could
win this i think i got to put my uh
invisalign in
right
brought to you by brian
i love that lisp that comes out when you
wear this that's great
bubbles come up so annoying got another
[ __ ] two months of this but my teeth
are going to be [ __ ] on point you got
to still wear them afterwards bell trans
beard you just got to cut yeah every
night when you go to sleep at night at
night
i had them there and they got some no
here we go
um here we go
he's gonna shoot right away oh oh oh oh
oh you're right he did try to take down
i'm so curious if we can get him down
because gilbert is no punk man
is the hype for reals we're gonna find
out
all right everybody calm down i think
he's going to realize this is the this
thing is
how compact gilbert is it's still tough
it's going to be hard for him to get him
down even when he does get him down i
don't know but then you got to worry
about the submission
his wrestling is
uh international
international wrestling but remember
there's no joke
hold up you're talking world champion
jiu jitsu yes he i know he's a
ridiculous athlete with michael chandler
he wrestled with marty for a long time
oh
dragon in the deep water dragged up
dragged him into deep waters here now
see a lot a lot of like a lot of the
daggers and wrestles instead of like you
driving you forward trying to take you
down they'll pull you backwards pull you
backwards just to wait
you know sit you on your hip
you're back on your butt yeah it's
easier to please not a lot of guys do
that oh he rolled with him
yes he did the side control yes he did
the hot does have to be careful you know
gilbert's no punk dude i told you he's
grounded pound
you're not going to submit gilbert burns
like you said
very hard harmon's got good submissions
i mean i'm not saying he's going to
submit him but no i think there's a
threat there though he can't take him
lightly
no he can't be real you know about
taking killer lately no yeah so i'm
saying like i can't i don't think he's
gonna be i can't i don't think
there's no way or hom's out on the
ground he can't just like yeah gilbert
can't take homs out no he i think he cut
him i think he already cut him didn't he
cut them that way that might be cut yeah
yeah they're cut i think
we're burning
back small
a lot of them oh
[Applause]
gosh that two grand sounding good right
now oh
no i'm gonna i thought the way for hobbs
out to win was on the feed gilbert
i know he is
the way for him to win is on the is on
the feet huh burns is on the ground it's
not the way man he's gonna waste a lot
of energy trying to get the fight to the
ground oh no
good job checking that that low kick oh
come on
[Applause]
i don't know man comes out dealing with
a [ __ ] killer here callahan hey come
on come on i told you we got a good hook
good job
good check hook good job yeah
i felt like the light kick was there for
gilbert dude it caused me so much stress
to watch people go back to that calf
kick chop them little legs
knock them skinny legs down chop those
skinny legs down daddy i'm daddy i'm
just got the skinny legs down how's
daddy can throw but gilbert's got some
power you guys are always counting
gilbert out gilbert's been knocked out
he's been knocked out against got
knocked down somebody
dude it's going to work this is what did
dana say that like literally everybody
in the road said no to fighting yes i
don't see anything out of cons out right
now
don't wow give it give give it a minute
give it i'm gonna i'm gonna go to the
first round
oh
gilbert has trained harder for this
fight than any other threat in his life
you don't know about that i do i do i
love that i do i do i'm the best i've
ever been on the feed house oh
[ __ ]
has the advantage but all right let's go
gil dude hamzad if one of those hooks
lands dude
oh that's got to be see that's where
gilbert needs to go go back to the legs
see i get i'm going to get that calf
dude kick that calf
god those cap kicks oh he's got skinny
legs look at how thick burns get them
skinny legs man you just kicking bone
right away
a little bit of muscle and bone kick
them legs
he is a little thin
dude that's one of my favorite moments
in a fight
the wrestling the wrestling's not going
to be the first see that [ __ ] jab
i told you it's gonna be the stand up
just like we practiced the power that
has in the stand up all right come on
gilbert that's how they answer backwards
the shooter takes one two that's all
it's the ones
that blood is that blood in the hairline
if if gilbert the same things aren't bad
they're not they're not bad at all he's
not using any wrestling the advantage
for him is on the feet
is that kick i don't think the advantage
for him is on the ground
i think that's the interesting part
about oh that could have been dirty wow
good liver hook that was a good little
lever shot amazing yeah he's cut pretty
let's go baby let's go
all right
let's see where it is now listen up
where is it got one more round buddy and
you gotta give me two thousand dollars
oh you got a little one ahead it's got a
little bit
it's in the hairline it's not bad one
more round
gilbert is tough as [ __ ] does slow down
though in the second third yeah he does
slow down no he's he's just gotta he's
all you gotta do is be patient i have a
lot of things i think you should shoot
in all this i do stress i do too yeah
down and take down some of the fence
make him work against defensive you're
saying
that was a jab that dropped him yes
yes
more like his right hand he's he's solid
softball yeah that's a nice chat that's
a great punch
that's what i felt like when kerotone
hit me and i was like don't let them see
that
just those elbows is that what cut them
up yeah yeah those are calms out elbows
that's why i call it that's why it comes
out in hamza comes out well comes out
means elbow in [ __ ] by the way i was
a rookie with ryan clark we were rookies
together with uh with the uh giants dude
and he was an undrafted free agent great
great dude
yeah great who's this uh ryan clark the
guy that does a show with dc
uh yeah
oh there's another kick kick man well
your good thing is like
henry's gym you're not gonna have virgin
legs so a little kick won't really
affect you that much your legs will be
ready for it yeah but you're just
needing something coming in man gilbert
needs to kick oh good there it is do it
again turn your back to the fence get
your back off the fence
back to the center that was a good
escape by a hums out
yeah it wasn't it wasn't a great shot
still but he didn't if you're a hamza
fan it's good that this is not it's
getting into like correct yeah so for me
right now this is what i want to see i
want to see
how he deals with the adversity like
someone doesn't fold where he doesn't
control them the way he controls
everybody else he's fought so far he
just dominated everybody yeah
but you know when you said good this is
a good test dude see if i'm killed i'm
throwing the inside low kick right now
against time's up all the damage look at
that jack like kill the inside of his
legs
oh
[ __ ]
oh dude that that's kind of laying in
there come on baby
well you had that very first low calf
kick that dropped him off to like
he didn't like that yeah you got to
throw it again like he hasn't gone back
to it since there it is
there he is good now put some power oh
don't chase him missed it though good
don't chase it okay get your head off
that's what i want to give her to throw
that rear cut left hook i think i'm
outside there are more combos
yeah gilbert needs to see that jab he's
a take down again there it is
come on baby you're not taking it down
no keep working that's okay make him
think about it though that'll slow him
down a split second right now go back to
the cafe yeah brian he's gonna go back
to the inside leg kick and calf case i
know i got a burrito i guess i got a
little purple right there i get nervous
man i get [ __ ] nervous yeah two
thousand dollars on the line that's not
what it is
oh
oh jesus let's go baby
oh [ __ ] oh blowing yes oh [ __ ] where's
that oh we rocked him oh come on
let's go
come
now yeah for either one
keep touching him keep touching him he's
tired you're working
he's tired
come on gilbert dude i love that i love
it i love them let's go
come on kick him in the calf again
gilbert
i want to be able to go forwards and put
some pressure on him
i want to see him fight going backwards
well you know who would make him go
backwards what's that colby covington
uh by the way i just bought i just
bought my first bit of bitcoin you guys
done that a lot you guys bitcoin people
at all oh boy oh boy
what's your focus on look at gilbert
answering back louise gilbert answering
back
don't kid yourself why did it get
yourself
oh there it is oh that's right it's
right it's right oh oh my god getting in
with that you know what
are you getting him with that oh gilbert
was that oh
i wish they would both like five seconds
just catch a breath and go back into it
oh oh that was a good shot by gilbert
jesus he shifts it guess who gets hit a
lot comes out i said stepped in calm
down it's home i call him
disrespect let's go come on
when we grew up in chechnya together we
used to always [ __ ] joke around and
that was his nickname we're hearing the
uppercut left hook girl even though i'm
out two grand now as long as that looks
like in the third round i gotta be
honest so do i come on come on
yeah he's slowing down he's been hit
dude come on give him fight and gilbert
burns let's go how many times i got to
tell you guys kick yeah damn leg kick
when he goes lefty 100 should be givers
winning this round man
yeah he's rocked him earlier he locked
him early on the round don't get greedy
don't lose him don't drop your hands
damn it come on
why is he turning like that because he's
trying to get away from that right
overhand right now i get it but
then i block it he's throwing he's
throwing his jab and he's counting
low kick there when he turns well he
there right there
come on let's go what do you mean don't
do anything now gilbert [ __ ] outside oh
nice to the body nice oh that was nice
though
nice again that could've been the case
working hey gilbert won this round yeah
he didn't say that
oh
that was fantastic they're made of
different stuff god look at this coach
yeah done hey guys got nothing left
he's got nothing left
hey this is the first time he's gone
third round didn't it first yes first
time he's ever been to the third round
yeah first yeah barely been out of the
second round first of all i just made
that up i totally exhausted
i didn't like how light he hit gilbert
with some good shots
that was starting he hit him hey let me
say
abraham lincoln got [ __ ] up though
abraham lincoln
john wilkes booth their son
1-1 oh wow 1-1 i'll tell you what
god damn zod has his hands yes he does
this is so awesome all right so this is
so i said this week on my show i was
like i haven't seen enough of him yet
i've seen enough of him now he's a
doctor he's [ __ ] not he's a dog yeah
dude
it wasn't that overwhelming
for him
that he was a [ __ ] guy he's a dog
he's a gangster he's a he's a dog hey
man you know i felt like he was trying
to like follow in the khabib footsteps i
smash you i'm gangster
yeah yeah yeah i agree now i want to see
him go against top level talent and do
it he's doing a great job right now such
a joke this is a great fight
yeah but he's also controlling tempo
he's controlling distance right he has
cage presence for sure okay now he's not
getting out
anyway no he's hit he gets hit but i
think he does get hit
that colby fight makes me not feel great
he wasn't sticking to the game
hey watching this kobe's like yes
because that'll be a that's fine
look at this watching that that'll be
the first time
this goes yeah i'll take it all day long
oh come on good god
come on gilbert
good fight though he's getting caught
inside low kick right now he's doing
he's using that jab that one
gilbert throws that inside low kick when
he switches left it stops his momentum
this is not good this is what i call an
educator jab guys
okay
get in there stay on it oh [ __ ] he
should have went for that punch yeah
that's not
by the way gilbert's going for this tape
look at this oh oh my god oh oh oh he
almost broke my legs
look at this gilbert doesn't have a neck
bro i'm sorry
look at that it just traps the ears on
look at this comes out had to calm down
and yeah oh my god now he's going to
start he's built like a yeah he's tired
he's too tired uppercuts
out of it oh oh [ __ ] oh
don't do it fight
[Applause]
because he's tired they're both tired
man they'll
he has to send it straight to i'm sorry
gilbert look at gilbert dance right back
you know i'm going to cash out to
gilbert brad
buddy
straight straight to the body hook up
top from gilbert now b you want to make
this even more interesting you want you
want does this fight go the distance
yeah
that's michael another two grand
double or nothing do we go two grand
ooh double or nothing half halfway
through the floor i don't think it's
going around i don't know
i think he's gonna get them out of there
i think i think contact gets them out of
there although he's so tired you just
need one big shot
there's a
there were two there were probably two
maybe three times in here where he could
have easily stopped especially when he's
basically this is where you see how good
comes out oh good god that hurt oh jesus
he'll still [ __ ] throw a little push
never mind not a great fight he went
back on it no he didn't
do that yeah exactly like you did to
rogan who did that crazy the rock
[Laughter]
some will get that job i can adore you
that's a good joke brandon don't worry
about it
oh [ __ ] gilbert answers [ __ ] in the
back if gilbert drops himself if you
were dropping he's going to win this
round it's a close round but it gets i
have comes out of the round that close
right now gilbert drops him or gets
taken a little bit
this fight anybody can lose this fight
anybody right now gilbert is just
[ __ ] and hops that's just going
forward too yup he just keeps a real
learning lesson for hamza yes it is
gilbert's a [ __ ] dog a dog a dog now
what a fight man now we're dude how many
people is parliamentary oh [ __ ] i don't
like that oh [ __ ]
oh greenery
exhausted keep pushing they're both
exhausted yeah shoot on them
just throwing one forward oh [ __ ] why
not shoot hamza
just throw see i want to see straight to
the body hook up top that's what i want
to see from you would you say that a few
times you're looking at the clock right
now that makes sense that makes sense
you just got to go this is hell gil's
got to just go standing upright keep
your head off the center line
throwing combination look at that look
at that and all
oh my god they kick them in the face
what happened there they kind of kicked
each other
holy what a fight
hey that was for real a lot of [ __ ] oh
you had the [ __ ] out of them i don't
know if that's how they're doing
chechnya but we do not do that here that
is not okay hey man
that you were 100 correct that wasn't
you thought he was wearing a football
hundred percent that hurts
jesus
you're such an aggressive life i never
think about it
i don't know man he had that that's the
word that's the biggest fight of his
life the hardest fight of his life what
do you go from fighting on rank the
number two guy yeah give me a [ __ ]
now
now i think he won it and you might have
won like for the from from uh unranked
to 11 to number two and you might have
won that you're damaged oh he won that
fight he won that fight comes out
yeah he won the first and he won them he
knocked him down first of all you
knocked him down in the first place i
always have to finish yeah yeah dude
that was a good job shouts out to
[ __ ] gilbert hell yeah so take that
fight when nobody would take it you're
number two you have no reason to take
that from you took it but then the ufc
didn't want to see that fight
so gilbert burns gave it gave him the
what for he gave him i don't think
thompson would be the favorite over
colby though
uh after watching that i don't think so
and after watching five rounds on abc
hope he's gonna have you on your back
foot the entire [ __ ] kobe's got that
he's got that cardio best guardio not
named him yes yes correct
calm down's kind of something gets hit
it's a little alarming he gets hit and
if he gets hit by kamara usman like that
that's such a good point good
yeah for now but they both hey they both
got dropped damn good fight though
see when i i was talking about this with
big john on our show i said hey i want
to see more out of him i want to see
this type of fight you show me like this
and i might say i'm not saying that i
need to see him like get dropped and i
want to see him get in trouble a little
bit i want to see him fight that's what
we're saying josh does this take like
what does this do for a fight like does
this is this good type you're saying
well no no no no does it take long
number two guys yeah builds it up more
makes him a better fighter yeah it makes
him happy you need to experience because
his longest fight's been like i think in
the second round right he's literally
mollywhopped
so he needed this this was good that was
such a good fight
i don't care if the [ __ ] fight stops
now the card that was amazing yeah
gilbert burns earned almost yeah he did
and if he wins this fight it's not the
end
he didn't win it though you know
[Music]
you'd be surprised no no not at all
you'd be very surprised display he won
i'm telling you man
the judge is giving it to colby i'm like
i'll take care of kobe i see like oh
he's not right exactly like no i think
he's going to get there
that's a fight but uh okay yeah let me
hear what hurricane
kobe coming to him on abc yeah if i'm
kobe i'm chomping at the bit dude i'm
like hold up you got tired in three
rounds oh i i warm up in the third daddy
i love this colby
100
you don't think disaster me cage side
for kobe covington
they're besties
nice
jen are you are you back are you on the
hum
are you a little like so i i thought he
was getting 29 20. i thought he was
going to win easily and i it's that's no
disrespect to gilbert but but when you
say yeah eleven to two we we thought
hamza was just a beast but eleven or two
that's like
possible not just we've never heard of
it really yeah yeah so i mean he did
really damn good yeah i'm on the ham's
house he was in trouble he fought a
world-class guy
dealt with adversity push so so what is
he's hard if you're his coach what do
you say to him when he comes home
he got who comes out he got hit a
so elbows uh he got hit a lot so what do
you say i think what you what we saw in
the beginning he's sitting on the fence
he's too much of a showman yeah focusing
on life
when it comes to the fight
when it comes to the fight look in there
comes the preparation the fight be the
showman conor was a showman but when it
came to the actual like walking into the
cage doing all those things
it was fight time uh-huh seems a little
too chill yeah especially at this level
at this level and so because even connor
had done those anticipations at this
level like those boys are there to
[ __ ] fight
you know you can walk out with
excitement but you're sitting on the
fence you're laughing your smile is
introducing you fighting number two in
the world yeah you're fight yeah this is
not i guarantee you doesn't do that
against colby yeah yeah not a shout out
and that's the thing though like you
always say dawg your mindset needs to be
focused on the fight and not being a
showman at that time the way kobe just
came out against um uh jorge
was was the best goalie i've ever seen
before like he looks so good and he's so
aggressive he's very very good and then
colby
on the planet not named dude if camaro
like whatever see that's born later
kobe's you're [ __ ] defending the
world champion but you you guys say that
and i know you guys probably hit me with
this but i think you said bellator i see
amazon amazon now i'm saying he's the
best i'm saying that there's a
conversation to be had there's 26 and
now there's not that you know tell me
why because he's not fighting the same
competition i get what you're saying day
in and day out i get what you're saying
but he didn't he didn't just show up in
bellator and all of a sudden be champion
he fought in the same leagues they all
fought and they came up but he was still
in defeat
they don't want to feed it
no i think he's damn good i i think he
could do some work in ufc i just want to
see it yeah i'd love to see it but
here's the thing though if you're taking
champion versus champion i would like to
see that i'm not saying he's going to
win i'm saying but look one guy has less
miles on him than the other guy for sure
so when you're talking about the fight
that's the other way of looking at it
how do you not lose no he is a monster
how do you not love this guy i dude
he's like
top five friendly skies
professional sports
he's a great husband dude him and his
wife are a hundred percent all the time
like his kids like they come to the gym
they are like the best family unit i've
i've i know periodically
just think about the giant brazilian
balls this guy has to fight harm nobody
wanted to fight that and then he did
really well oh dude he was around put
him on notice put him on notice so so so
i'm talking about style like he he was
getting hit is there something you do
like i guess you you go back
cause he was getting caught and that's
really bad for a lot of that brian he's
fighting the number two guy in the world
you're not gonna not get hit no don't
think he can't fight but he but he
leaves himself he leaves himself
yeah
he reaches a lot he overextends a lot
and that's that's easier for that's easy
though for long guys he also couldn't
really get him down either yeah for long
guys though for long guys so do you
think so is he going to get colby down
absolutely yeah and cole's going to
penetrate so damn fast
i would say this
i would say this about colby though
kobe's [ __ ] mostly kobe is mostly
folk wrestling right and freestyle
comes out as more that russian style and
i feel like they have an easier time
against freestyle uh folk wrestling yeah
because it's traditional styles
and they they so they're speaking like
chinese you're coming and they're
speaking french like they have different
styles i've said that like when i said
it's just really tough to take colby
down
i think i think you had luke how big is
that
and luke was i said you're gonna see
something different from um you know
from from like khabib to justin gates
wrestling i said the american style
wrestling versus that that dexterity
style wrestling you don't even know what
the [ __ ] it's different it's completely
different and it just proves to be right
like it's just different in terms of how
they match up now geichi's not the level
of wrestler that like a khabib is in
terms of that style right now he's a
good good good good good nor does he's a
good wrestler but he's not
just yes he doesn't use it now that's
the thing
she's a stud man oh
you can't die in fact he's not
yeah he's a stud who wins that fight
uh i'll take him
hey you have not remembered gaijin i
came up with kj i'm a hometown voice so
don't ask me when are you uh when is
your special dropping oh my god brian i
can't believe you asked gringo poppy
you're talking about the gringo talking
about the gringo pop dude it drops april
28th i can't wait on thick boy youtube
yep 30 minutes of pure fury yeah you've
seen it you've seen it
isn't dick boy producing my special at
the break we are and this isn't about
you though but i like that you said all
right i'm just asking this is more about
mine
on the 28th which is very
soon yours have like a really cool uh
name too like the gringo come on i don't
know
you know what your boy's gonna come up
with it well come on i'm producing brian
special yeah nice
now great big boy youtube yeah how long
are you catching me 30 minutes
maybe i mean listen
i'll tell you what's insane how good my
nuts feel dude because listen my friends
at manscape the global leaders and below
the waist hygiene are turning men's
shower dreams into their favorite
routine with the all-new ultra premium
collection this all-in-one hygiene skin
and hair bundle is designed to upgrade
the every day man shower routine from
head to toe your skin here and balls
deserve this save big by going to
manscape.com for 20 off and free
shipping with the code cfc let me walk
you through the manscape shower routine
listen your boy here my i get my thick
ass in that shower i lather on the clone
infused ultra premium body wash dude i
love aloe vera and salt yeah daddy i
love it and it's hair care time now i go
oh oh you know what time it is it's hair
care time it's two in one shampoo
dude and then once i hop out of the
shower it doesn't stop there and protect
yourself from smelling like matt
matrione and apply the manscaped
aluminum free deodorant
does it dry clear though does it dry
clear it is it is it alone infused you
have to worry about getting those
shirts and then oh do you have tattoos
or super dry skin like in the face right
now yeah let's get your skin a little
hydrating body moisturizer spray they
got everything that's our
nice daddy they got everything for your
shell okay for the shell your lips yeah
they're chapped my lips get all
different you need manscape lip balm wow
that's right dude then last but not
least we're using the lawnmower 4.0
electric trimmer to clean off any
unwanted body hairs like calen's
shoulders the lawnmower 4.0 is
waterproof so you bet it's a major key
to the new shower routine all right we
got you guys covered man the new bundle
will change your life
and we want all the listeners and
viewers out there to live their best
lives
get 20 off plus free shipping with the
coach cfc at manscape.com is 20 off plus
free shipping with the code csc
manscape.com it's time to get wet and
clean with your new manscape shower
routine
manscape i respect that dude i can't
tell you how much more energy i have
after eating i've had 400 calories all
day
okay and i ran for three hours you did a
great job impressive yeah
undulating three hours uh he might be in
the best shape for a big man
oh i'm not going to do that now i
couldn't do it now uh you know that uh
peter young's going to win this fight
yeah
uh you know he's like a minus 700
favorite
yeah
meatball or somebody said someone uh
take these dishes
do you mean to call them dishes you know
but
that bar i will i will
chug this barbecue sauce here you go
meatball god he's such a killer he's
such a killer
oh god meatball even though he's not
very meaty he's not dude i was watching
a guy in tough mudder today i went oh
that's a meatball he's like short and
fat i was like that's a meatball there
we go change your name up
you're more like a little salami you
know it's just what i used to eat when i
was a little kid i could see salami you
got a little red tint to them anyone
ever call you a little salami yeah
pepperoni
meatloaf to be funny meatloaf dude look
i'll rest in peace that's
good
salami is kind of nice yeah a little bit
yeah you have red tint to the beard kind
of and then you have the like the white
freckles on the face hey does anybody uh
so
anyway i was i was listening i was like
the hair's like a little bit of salt and
pepper so like you have that like
peppered uh yeah i feel like you're on
the other hand tortellini i like that
yeah um anybody have algerian sterling
beat him beating peter young
coming off the neck surgery
i think i think i think honestly he's
gonna have a better performance than the
first fight
he has to he looked terrible the first
fight his only strengths are his guile
and acting skills and and i had sterling
going into that fight i thought
athletically i i've never been really on
that peter you're on train dude after
that fight went holy i mean i've been on
the peter young he beats everybody
yeah but yeah but either way i'm not on
trains or planes this guy is good man i
know
you want to go to russia his tenacity
going into that that third fourth fifth
round i know championship rounds he's
built for five no he won me he was i'm
telling you i was i remember on the
train and then i watched the outdoor
interior i went holy [ __ ] yeah he's very
he's the real his striking is so high
level dude his tenacity he is just not
well he's he's highly aggressive he's
got serious takedowns and he's he's
so athletic and like he's awkward so i
figured it'd be a tough matchup he was
getting algerman to step right into his
right and his left
you
know
oh i'm sorry go ahead
john's only lost legit loss outside of
the the alger thing was to margaret
margaret off who's in bellator but he's
insane
the first fight yeah then john beat them
in the second fight but he resolved it
the first he gets better in all of his
rematches he learns and figures out what
you do
well i think without jermaine here
because al james is technically the
champ quote unquote i think peter
johnson would make an example i think
he's gonna make it nasty yep look at him
look at him he can't wait i i know how i
could maybe win back my money go ahead
remember these aren't
chin's gonna like this these aren't his
corners
so they can't come over i'm two g's up
your two g's up okay now what do we do
because am i up overall i think no no i
think we were tied here so
but he can't have his normal coaches
because they're russians
you know why though okay any questions
about peter young you directly i'm on
i'm on board now he's he's a he's a
professional russian boxing
why do i know that coach on the right
why do i know him that guy oh he's fr
oh he's uh he's everywhere
oh my god who is that that's an american
top team guy
is it police
yeah cause he's with uh with a big fella
uh not even big fella he's with the girl
too the beast joanna yeah anything with
you
i think so is that right chin
typing guy with tattoos
now wait what were you saying
oh how you can make your now
dude this is a stretch so i need some
odds here okay i think the only upset of
the night yeah could be and china's
gonna love this korean zombie yeah
versus
the great volkanovsky why would
[Music]
look at our boy at t.j dillashaw right
now just looking at peter young oh that
now that's that's [ __ ] fine i didn't
get that big boy i didn't see it that's
the title that's my boy it's the fight
now now uh so you want to go you want to
go you want to go 2 grand
on on what
how about this you want me to take the
koreans off me no i want the korean
zombies really yeah but hold on these
are the odds you ready for this guy now
he's like
minus 14 000 or whatever or plus 14 000.
no he's
plus 475
which is insane right that's not so if
korean zombie wins you give me five
grand
if
volkanovsky wins by however i'll give
you a hundred bucks
that's a horror odds i think that's
hey trust me compared to your first
because you didn't do a really good job
negotiating the first time let's be
honest here still won by two grand yeah
i'm telling you i knew burns wasn't
going to get i was like burns is not
going to get finished
i'm still on the hamsa
it's the same with you remember anthony
and joshua they had that crazy uprise
and then when he fought [ __ ]
no no no no he got he lost that one that
was terrible oh when he [ __ ] up
no
klitschko
and he won that but he got knocked down
twice and he got up and knocked him down
oh now i can now i can now i can best
stalk him because he's an actual fighter
when they're just mopping through guys
it's like i don't know
i don't know yeah you're right yeah
you're right so that's why i invest in
anthony joshua these shots
this video this video work they're doing
right now is [ __ ] insane
the way they're getting the crap the
smoke in the background the walk out
from the back they're still in a
downtown they're making it like that
yeah it was it looks like it's more
impressive dude you know what's more
impressive they've put energy into
jacksonville yeah you've been to
jacksonville going down there even the
water doesn't [ __ ] move
i think they get along with the
the the governor
are you guys moderately familiar with
jackie
i'm going down there
is it jacksonville beach is that the
place to stay uh no i've spent i've
performed there a couple times there is
an area you want to stay in and there's
an area you don't want to stay in yeah
and i can't remember where the [ __ ] it
is but there's a place
i stayed at the best hotel there i found
the best hotel because i was like i
gotta oh i know it was the red roof red
roof yeah there's a cool area
there's a cool area of jacksonville yes
yeah there's a really ritzy area yeah go
to the ritzy area oh you know what you
should do oh no i got this you know i
should do don't go don't go yeah but
don't go to jacksonville jackson
remember that uh
two months now jacksonville i'll be
there this thursday friday saturday come
get your ticket remind bernie sanders
look at that he comes out of that camp i
love that i love that guy dude he's so
dope love those guys he's so delicious
the best i like al james
is [ __ ] stunned
yeah ray long was great lovely
a lot of pressure on al jermaine here
right because you're the champ but
everyone knows you're really not the
champ right and then you've been saying
your champion he's kind of been a little
cringy about it which i don't mind do
you think there's a lot of pressure on
him a hundred percent i don't think
there is because you gotta prove that
you like you know what i'm saying i
think
the thing is he's still gonna be number
one number two ranked right
so on top of that like he's gonna
probably get another if he continues to
do what he's doing he's stud he's a stud
absolutely he's floating around top he's
loading on that top three is al still
fighting because he looks pretty small
though
no nobody said jose aldo oh al is the
only guy who stopped khabib from taking
him [ __ ] down i mean uh al quinta is
really good at podcasting is he really
he's a podcast he's wrong dude he's a
gangster i like owls i've got him on the
show he's great yeah i've got i've done
like a couple appearances with him yeah
not playing around he's i'm telling you
he's going to make this miserable for
algerian if he can
but algebra is so athletic it's tough he
is going to brian do you want the bet
5100 i will take i will take it beat the
piece
it's pure
he is gangster just go by peter just go
by peter though you know theater peter
that's better better better have you
ever heard al jermain's story about his
girl who's a dying piece they're at a
vegas pool party and floyd mayweather
doesn't know who al germain is yeah and
floyd's walking through the pool bar
sees the girl and goes like this
and now jermaine's like what the [ __ ]
and goes down there yeah and the body
goes like what are you doing he's like
no you gotta let him know man like that
will [ __ ] him up at the time they didn't
know he was like yeah
oh good for him good friend is right and
he will [ __ ] him up
yeah there's no doubt about it
very good bro before you hit the [ __ ]
ground
yeah you know sometimes you got to lay
[ __ ] down guys because otherwise it gets
you know
it
out of every podcast i do you guys have
the best food
oh thank you
good job that last try tip was
absolutely fantastic absolutely my boy
mike doing it well it's also from that
burbank joint what's it called mike
that's what i'm hey handy market how
many times i have spent [ __ ] 200 on
[ __ ] come out the damn pockets god
god damn it dude jesus
dude he's got he's got
a bag of tricks in his shorts this is
what what this is what scares me about
this fight alex is going to come out so
relaxed because no one thought he won
the first fight he has nothing to prove
i you say he does i don't think he does
i think there's so much i think he's so
relaxed look
he's already playing the hill everyone
hates him already because of what
happened last fight he's got nothing to
prove come out there relax fight which i
feel bad for him because it wasn't
really his two thousand it wasn't his
humor it wasn't his heart i ragged on a
little bit because what i didn't like
was the acting at the end
what who want i want you want you know
you won you know what you were doing
just whatever take the belt and run i
understand okay like it wasn't your
fault you got knee in the face illegally
by the way one better drop 9.9 k on
alger main sterling payout 41 thousand
dollars a lot of coins um
in my opinion if hey listen if you get
fouled and you're affected
as well
there's no benefits
dude i think
there's there's no warning automatic
deduction
kicks to the groin automatic point
deduction there should be no warnings
there's strength does it change the
outcome
but it's hard though like if the guy
steps in and you're throwing the kid it
doesn't matter it should be no like a no
policy it shouldn't be no you should be
chasing dudes around with your cup then
like [ __ ] dick out just if you get
kicked in the nuts you should stop
fighting because you're going to have
the i folk situation i get it i
understand that like this you either
learn how to fight with your eyes closed
or you don't do that
yeah
you know what's weird they wouldn't let
me talk to my corner they would i didn't
know what my options were it was real
there are no options your options are
can you see yourself you're not yeah
[ __ ] i told them those are your options
[ __ ] i'm seeing doubles did you take
your five minutes but they want to give
me my favorites well that should have
been overturned yeah right
five minutes there's no five minutes fry
was that in connecticut no i was in san
jose by the way you know that guy still
never ruled on that headbutt
what's his name oh mike missouli mm-hmm
that was in july oh good shot right now
he's got those russian hipsters those
hips he's got some hits he's got those
he's not rushing himself he was training
with him he was trying to
i still saw all those guys in over in uh
tiger muay thai no tiger movies call him
i call him daxter hips
yeah they were all there at the same
time for like a couple weeks
yeah haven't you guys been there look at
peter yeah peter young just walks
through thailand
he kind of the first round takes off he
downloads your data and then he goes to
work second third is a good pressure
fighter look at it look at look at this
he always fights better he's already
fought him so he understands what he
does well so he'll fight him better the
second time yeah oh jermaine is moving
uh now i don't want to skip over the
fact that matt matron was in thailand
oh that got real weird i bet it got so
weird
you know my fat friend would he was out
there
just seems to get be able to get your
face right down that pipe just no matter
what you do he's fine
he's got good bodies i don't like he's a
very he stays tight he doesn't open up
too much he's a good defensive fighter i
don't like how brian said face and pipe
that's weird right it goes right at your
mouth i see things like that
it's a boxing terminology
i did a lot of sparring guys in my 50s
matt over underneath that's with two
ladies
in the 50s or in your 50s no but he's
it's a dude first of all second of all
there was one chick that came out of a
dark out we had a rule go down every
dark alley and thailand uh and we did
and we had a great time with most of
them
one camera the rule was go down every
dark album every dark alien talent i
feel like the rules should be the
opposite of that and patia it was
fantastic absolutely exquisite uh and
then one the biggest ass i saw on
anybody in thailand she walked out and i
was like oh my god we gotta chase her
down so i changed and started talking to
her and i was like
drunk she like i was like are you like
are you a lady now or you've always been
a lady and i'm weird drunk hammered
yeah aggressive question and slides it
up her skirt and i didn't feel a [ __ ]
and i was like i think that that's a
chick but then like the next day i was
like i think that might have been a dude
and a dude and a dude that was with was
like hey you know what i'm gonna take a
chance
and uh but that dude him and you but you
don't know i'll tell you i'll tell you
if it was me um
that was a good combination there
and then uh so we we went there and by
the time we got up to uh the room mm-hmm
there's just swinging dick over there
and i was like wow this oh this just
really got weird so the dick was out it
was out it was i heard thailand it's
very tough to tell dude if they look too
good they're dude i'm telling you the
the the prettiest women i've ever seen
were lady boys there 100 the hottest
[ __ ] girls or the russian chicks
there yeah the russians lady boys too no
they're just really hot chicks hey but
if they're the hottest streaks you've
ever seen there's happen to be dudes
back in the day does it matter
something sure so uh we landed there let
me answer that question yes it doesn't
matter bro i don't know let me ask you
it was the hottest chick you've ever
because you guys just skated over it let
me answer that for you like the 90s
yeah um so we're in pattaya and uh we
land in bangkok and it was right after i
fought in uh macau so we've jumped over
there me and uh three of my buddies
and uh we have no idea where we're going
we fly into bangkok and dude's like hey
we're having political protest the guy
at the visa desk where i'm putting a
protest can't you guys can't stay here
you have to go somewhere else here's who
you're with i tell them me and these
three dudes he's like you guys are going
to patie sounds great we have no idea
where patia is we jump on the interstate
or the highway we drive all the way
through this third world chancey town
finally get to this place and he's like
where are you guys going to stay no clue
it was he's like we're going to take you
to boys town takes us to this place
called the penthouse hotel you've heard
of this before no never dude let me grab
my phone it's called the boys town
there yeah
i don't want to go there but he was
setting you up to go to boise because he
was three it was four dudes and he's
like oh i get it so like he's just all
right
you thought you guys were in the guys
yeah i thought you guys were in the cox
yeah yeah well so now so then like we're
there for three days right yeah i get my
suits made and [ __ ] there about blah
sweatshops little kids probably whatever
okay so um
i thought he was gonna shoot that carry
on the story got really sad yeah so we
walk around and then we always see
like these russian dudes or these
europeans
walking with walking with two with two
chicks all the time yeah josh so we come
in the hotel like hey man like one that
you don't why do we always see
these european dudes these white guys
walking with two chicks like ah wow
one's a [ __ ] one's a chick
and i was like i don't understand why
bring a ladybug at the same time i don't
get it that nice long baby because their
dudes have bigger mouths
physically they're bigger so they do
fellatio the ladyboys do fellatio and
the dudes and then the dudes hit the
chick yeah but i don't believe any of
that in other words like
that's some guy who said that you know
some guy some guy that's some guy in the
third round with his gayness
it's your fantasy and no one said that
and that's what you're thinking that's
your outside voice that's your inside
voice maybe that's way on the outside
or or it sounds like you're dick sucked
by a dude but they went hey dude but
their mouths are brighter so it's not
gay and you went that makes sense
and you brought the story back here very
specifically well i mean ladyboys
are larger really listen i'm going to be
talking about this video listen if i let
me basically ever hooked up with it with
it with a uh with a [ __ ] i'm like
yeah [ __ ] i did it okay yeah i'm married
didn't matter anymore this here we go no
it doesn't i would respect you i would
resp i respect you anyway but i'd be i'd
be very happy if you did it now and i'd
be happy for the [ __ ] because you've
got big hands and you're just a big
handsome wider mouse yeah and you have a
wide mouth now here's the thing
what what uh
what i don't see much of a that
that round was close
we stayed at in the penthouse hotel this
is the room let me see that have a good
time
you see that i mean how can you sleep
with all that i walked i swear to god my
hand on the bible i walked down i was
like listen
i feel like ronald mcdonald dropped acid
and designed this room i've got to get
the [ __ ] out of here it's like i'm going
to kill somebody here you're going on a
seizure you can have a seizure yeah yeah
oh look at that
it looks like [ __ ] look at peter
young constantly pushing forward
constantly pushing forward that's right
just a nightmare you have uh i don't
know
john first round yeah
josh first rounds yeah yeah pressure
yeah pressure some good shots too alger
tried to take downs he stuffed them
quick and easy look at this look at
young he just can sit there right in the
pocket like that now he says nah no no
your take downs
now i hit you back
[ __ ] just sits there like now
look at that snatch that single leg snap
oh oh oh oh get us back oh that's a oh
he's the mountain he's gonna get oh yeah
oh [ __ ] good that's not good
oh and al jamae is nasty on the back now
that's his this is his thing dude
this is his thing holy [ __ ] brian
look at those look at those look at that
body line we've been five minutes three
minutes and 30 seconds that's a long
time to be in a body locker
oh god what do you do in this situation
how do you get out of a body lock he's
just gonna have to turn in on him turn
it against him keep too long he's just
gonna hang out there and go sterling
i'll get through rounds three four five
sterling's leg is too low he's not
losing dude algerman on your back that's
his that's his most dominant position
he's filthy on there
he made a little mistake that's how he
that's how he's going to hang out
he's a he's a magician on your back now
my muscles are flexible
yeah
my body
yep it's not fun
it's not fun
alger man is very relaxed here
he should be
he's in a good position this is his best
friend for him it's literally the best
case scenario it's all to get his back
that's what he does
brian were you and uh brendan friends
before he stopped fighting
or was that at the end of the career no
he he was that i was at your fight he
was outside your fight were you really
yeah dude he yelled for that he yelled
[ __ ] matt rip his head off no no
actually i think i heard that i would
take him down take him down and take him
down i don't remember that i i don't
remember
i
i looked up brian i went calm down dude
but get thumbs up we were friends for uh
for a while before that actually yeah a
while how long ago was that because i
was a coach on the ultimate fighter when
we met you became friends yes
we fought
13
13 13. dude that's i've known you all
i've known you ten years just
controlling that
dude jesus christ crazy how'd you guys
meet
there's a gay bar called ram rob
oh we met at a bar was the bar called he
goes and he goes
he's not gonna be happy i'm talking
about this at all
yeah
brandon said you're coming home with me
and i was like no i got a girl he goes
coming home with me and i was like well
i i i wrestled from high school her
adam's apple does not move like yours
nope
i said i heard your mouth is wider
[Laughter]
that's right
that's so funny
oh [ __ ] dude
oh [ __ ] oh oh oh no
dude can you imagine the satisfactory
he's gonna have if he chokes him out oh
i'm telling him he is a magician oh he's
lost
yeah but he's still mountain beating the
[ __ ] out of him
that's not good for uh peter young i'm
kind of rooting for alger maine as well
you should root for al james this is
incredible this is incredible
dude he's [ __ ] him up there one round
one one one minute she's got to survive
this round dude how's this not attending
a long time it's not it's it's so
dominant though josh
we gotta give more ten eights these yeah
see i agree but you actually gotta get
close to a finish i'm gonna go ahead and
throw this out there i actually think
vader being nose girls because he kicked
his [ __ ] at me
look at this look at peter young now
what's he doing now
he keeps giving his back though well
yeah but i like i like i like when he's
on top because he had a better chance
he's got he's got good defense obviously
what i meant was he sure he's on his
back he keeps trying to go belly down
like what are you doing man when peter
goes down he gets [ __ ] up yeah yeah
just stay here dude yes stay there stay
in this position
look at him
relaxing
these guys really don't get tired though
they don't care man no he knows he knows
in the in rounds three four and five
it's going to be him
and let's see it's a lot less hitting
him from behind
ends
yeah but this is a lot of work on the
legs man for al joe i don't know is it
though it's a lot of work for peter
young
squirming that figure four is it's so
hard to hold for that long yeah you guys
gonna tire three seconds i'll try
that's the good height right there where
it's coming across look at that look at
that just walk back to your corner what
a not a big deal
a little confident oh
stare him down dad that's how you do it
you stare him down yes king you stare
him down bro yes king stare him down
it's all about domination dude that's me
so i remember the other series i was
gonna tell you about earlier today okay
that was a long time ago but it was
the last kingdom oh okay have you
watched it how is that it's exceptional
utrecht on a food trade what is the last
kingdom last kingdom we were talking
about series earlier it's about vikings
or something yeah it's great hey real
quick peter's cornerman looks like the
guy from south spark goes okay
bring that up chin
he's the teacher he goes um
they have the same head he does have
look at him dude you you are the best in
the world coming up
drugs are bad okay
drugs are bad kids okay that's good
he looks identical to him that's a good
call i'm impressed yeah
man what a round for alger man that's
gotta be such a confidence booster
probably don't get too confident in it
no i if anything you know it gives him
more motivation he's like i can hang
with this [ __ ] dude
listen now chin do we know if the
crowd's chanting usa usa i can't hear it
because i feel like they should right
this should especially whenever
that stan uh championship mentality and
stand up guys do you have a second wait
okay never mind
got it now who is the guy in the
comments oh tie back there oh that's a
great counter kick there look at those
kicks look at those [ __ ]
violence uh-oh
see i like i like i like you too let's
go out jermaine get in there dog
he's got those dagger standing hips
all right i'm just saying man i'm gonna
[ __ ] hit you but his hips are [ __ ]
dude i answer back don't because my
elbows are feeling so [ __ ] heavy you
know i can't wait for our butt 5000 to
100. al joe put his knee on the ground
right away
gotta put your knee in the ground he's
like he's down he's down look at this
come on better better better
baby
all the haters you're not the real
champion look at them
are you telling me he's not he's not the
real champion he can turn into top he's
gonna be able to turn it off hey
certainly might not be a good spot
because his legs on the inside like john
might be able to turn it inside the
inside
he could i feel like he'd
yeah it's hard to breathe
oh he's putting the arm on the head oh
that was nice but that was really nice
that was filthy he put the arm behind
his back
[Laughter]
it's another three minute session
it could be another three minute session
matt
casey loved that
uh oh oh oh oh oh oh there you go
dude whenever you grab something leaves
your neck wide open leave your neck wide
open there you go
it's not good man this is not good that
very smart move to be
doing those takedowns dominating right
now
alto alto's winning this i want aojo to
win he's winning this
he's winning this and i told him you
know i don't like you guys are
not very patriotic today well no i
better see you
i put five grand on the mountain and you
were the one who didn't want it
did you want to do that no no i got algo
oh me too
no i got pet there still i'm still about
to switch them up i still got better
yeah
so listen al joe might have found out
might have found i i
bet you i bet uh yon might win the next
one i bet you al joe gets him down again
in the fifth and we go through this
again he wins three to two i think we're
gonna talk about this al joe found a
chick in his armor um josh would you
like to explain to the fan base at home
if you have a body lock a body triangle
and he puts the foot on the bottom side
the pressure the escape out of that you
want to talk about that yeah so what you
do is you see that bottom knee and you
kick it forward so you kick that hill
forward so it loosens up so you can spin
into it okay but see how he keeps
hooking it behind the knee yeah so it's
harder yeah it's harder to control that
yeah
so what he's gonna do now
actually john's gonna escape from there
as well but see how he stepped on it
stepped on it trying to open it up that
was nice
but y'all can get him in a submission
there as well when you put the foot
behind the knee knees
all he's got to do is go
chest to back bridge into him and like
hip into his his leg as well it's kind
of a little bit of an ankle lock knee
lock submission and if you're not if
you're in that body triangle you want to
try to get the other the person with the
body like you want to get their foot to
the ground yeah you wanna get their foot
to the ground use your knee just like he
did he stepped on it and used his needle
this is frustrating he's gotta spin
right away uh-huh the fact that he keeps
getting to this position
his belly is troubled yeah i don't know
why i don't know he does that it's
usually arrested doesn't reality he
doesn't even have it unlocked yet that's
what that's what's baffling me by it all
yeah it's a waste of energy aldo's not
really doing a lot here
he's waiting for his time he's also
winning every second
yes he is yes he is yes is
you're going to lose five g's in this
fight
look man i'm just oh i know i have a
time share in russia
yeah he's i'm trying to get to use it
that's how it is
fighting with anger
al james is fighting oh he's unlocked
right now it's unlocked though so he
just unlocked it which is nice
see now he needs to spin there he goes
yeah all round over that's tough that's
it
that's two look at him but look at him
he's not even breathing hard he's nice
chase but his legs gonna be dead after
that you wish i don't think so you wish
haters i don't think so man
look john's kind of tired dude
yep look man we practiced this
uh-oh what's the big dude's name from
american top team the big guy yeah
what's his name i'm paulina blank greg
hardy the big lambert no no no the coach
lambert no name is the owner yeah and
then other dude he's great there's mike
brown uh he called her something like
conan
yeah that's the other guy that's the
other guy that's always a kid
yep that guy looks like a smaller conan
yeah
yeah
conan's got that is conan still there
yeah he's got him so yeah i believe so i
think him and dan lambert are homies
forever yeah
because who opened up black house
i'm sorry uh that was what's his name he
used to own
sinister or something like
i'm telling you oh [ __ ]
use those hips use those
illegal knees coming
oh boy oh boy
that guy in the bowtie is driving me
nuts you guys see him oh there's vitoria
young right now
dude you ever seen his girl
yes his wife bro yeah
look at this look at this look at this
oh yeah jesus oh jesus
oh geez
patrion's punches
was brazil that was a reality show it's
like big brother brazil yeah john was
sucking on the toes
oh oh oh oh what was that hips again
hips
just like we worked on in dagestan come
on
gonna give up this fourth round in this
fifth round i think he's just giving it
up or he's losing it he's losing it he's
getting his ass what oh
um
oh he's gonna roll for him that's a good
purple shirt that dude had though oh the
ref got kicked now here you're trying to
keep him from closing his hands yeah
look at the guy in the bowtie
you see him
all right
who's arguably the better wrestler
it's probably alger man
more decorated for sure yeah was he was
he he's a wrestler yeah he's backwards
yeah yeah yeah he's got good wrestling i
didn't know that he got a good top
position
oh i like the faints by al james
me too i'm telling you dude looks like
he's
oh no there's no nut shot there good for
him that that right yeah
that was nice that was nice
um you know you know what you're always
getting him down again and getting his
back that's a great job this is how we
do it this is it come out the back door
here panther young peter young come
outside
he's really high he's got to win this
tyler oh [ __ ] down
remember what happened when owler got
put on his back
yeah that fight that that fight took a
turn for the worst suit how bored is ron
desantis look at him
yeah he's burning
dude look at these [ __ ] was rhonda santa
he was in the military he wasn't a seal
though right
who's the kid in the brown shirt is that
vitor's son uh sounds like one he's like
a holy recruit no
one of the top five recruits on high
school quarterbacks
he committed to alabama pretty really
that's how big of a deal he is good for
him that's impressive as hell yeah uh
ron desantis he's born in jacksonville
that kid has been busting his balls in
football forever vitor's kid he's been
busting his balls forever and he works
so hard dude he does a great job works
with tony vallandi down in uh xpe no
doubt dude uh desantis graduated from
yale then went to harvard ever heard of
it brian
joined the united states navy where he
was promoted to lieutenant before seeing
adviser to a seal but serving as an
advisor to seal team one awesome and
being deployed in iraq he's awesome okay
he's got my vote so what's
up someone told me he was part of the
secret service too he's probably sure
does it all dude not stuff we can talk
hey hey you know what
you're welcome for your freedom
now
he wins round four i'm surprised he
didn't stand and bang he's i told you he
was gonna give him round four yeah i
think they should do like uh
he gave him he gave him round four can
you hear that
oh we're going prison rules john huh
yeah
oh
roll for the
that's not good for
look at this definitely not there not
villains now horrible
how tired he's gonna be yeah
well
john's got to win this fifth december
says no i don't know what he's watching
it's a great fight though man it's gonna
be 2-2 going into this right
yeah dude hey this whole fight this
whole card has been pretty damn good
this is the whole club it's been a
hangout i like that
how i'm exhausted from this card in a
good way
i need to cry on somebody's chest
controlling time how the oh there we go
yeah two and three yeah look at this
better come on better yes better
you see you see how all joe has that
hook on the left one yeah over the leg
he's gotta pull that hook back more so
he could have went to his knees start
opening the heel a little bit more kind
of put a twist in his hips
on that hip you know what we say would
do i wish they would put his hips um a
heart rate monitor inside the inside of
the glove or the wrap so that way when
they're in the middle of it you can see
what their heart rate is like how much
they cool them down like in between
rounds i can see the drops you think
yeah you think anybody would give a [ __ ]
that's a good idea i think they would
because you you could better tell how
tired somebody was yeah right
exhaustion factor i think it's tough
enough like what do you want to see like
i think it's keep people interested he
has a good idea that's a good idea okay
i think it'd be good to see like how
much i said
breathe okay
i do think it'd be interesting though to
see what his heart i think i'm gonna
push you out of your chair here sam
he's gonna get his shovers on get your
shovers on and start shoving
i'll help you i'll help you bully me man
this is the it comes down the fifth
round i know he's gonna be world
champion no pressure look at him fire it
up yeah
usa
this is it and dude in your fight in
front of a patriot elder man
think about that he's so big he looks
like he weighs 200 pounds he's a patriot
he looks like he's 200 pounds
there's one more fight after this
there is
doesn't have a boring fight on his
resume
here we go here we go here we go brian
bet 5 000 100 bucks how long was his uh
oh no no no no no get up that that's not
where you want to start no that's not
where you want to start somebody had two
year hiatus right because he had to go
to uh the uh army serving south carolina
south korea you gotta do it it was two
years right two years ago he was
actually out three was he really yeah
yeah he he lost to aldo and then did his
time and then came back and went on a
rampage oh oh
oh he had it he owned it he had it stay
on it he had it he did have it there's
just almost too much momentum you know
uh that's one of the biggest differences
between the bellator cage and the ufc
cage is that the ufc gauge has a space
between the mat and the fl in the cage
it's actually a pretty significant
difference wait what what do you mean
see how it goes it's called like an
infinity wall see how it goes the cage
goes down below and there's no feet can
go into that little pocket and it's like
an extra layer of defense oh jesus brian
you're learning how the hot dog is made
right i sure am buddy i'm sure a little
over your head sure how do you just hit
him with a nice body shot right now
and he's got a good job for the fifth
round bet there's pet there's boxing is
just a nightmare
but i'll do oh i don't like that shot's
too far out al james a little bit i
thought you needed to get close to the
hook
oh good elbow there
oh
go to the back he keeps turning his back
you're riding it daddy i just lost you
why is he turning his back turns his
back you know he's doing that with corey
sanderhagen you remember that he's doing
against tj drove me nuts now now he gets
out of this this is not a takedown yet
is it no but it's controlling control
it's control control
i would throw some nasty knees here to
the back of those juicy quads there we
go
okay um
i've never seen one episode of south
africa look at you on turn yeah
look at young turtles i don't watch that
tv but
dude
we got three minutes
i've never seen one episode in style
park but i've
also thought he could come in
i've never watched one episode of
seinfeld sorry i watched one the uh
super super nazi oh yeah soup nazi i
watched that one
wow
i know i just i don't watch a lot of tv
dude oh [ __ ] i didn't either but look at
this i thought he's gonna cut that angle
come back on his back so so who's gonna
win the guy pushing the pressure trying
to get the takedown
you know control there for about two
minutes not two minutes
a minute yeah give him a minute oh yeah
he's gonna
just keeps pressuring though he keeps
pressuring
i don't like that slogan there i know
oh oh you try to get him a little bit
because his hips look like they're in
there and then he backs them away
so [ __ ] good yeah they are
oh jesus that counts for something there
guys
let's definitely win you some points
with it i'll win you some points brandon
with putin when you go to russia
look at this oh no no we don't want this
again no no don't alternate get up
he's he's resting he's [ __ ] resting
dude well he's tired with a minute 45
left in the championship belt's on the
line you got to get up dude
pop up homie that's a lot of pressure on
him he's going to hang out here don't do
it now does he win this
there you go get up
oh he's dragging hanging him backwards
al jermaine dude into his butt i'm in
your corner i'm like dude this is the
fight you got to get up in [ __ ] hand
fighting that's a good job right there
oh
if i'm peter i don't do that i don't let
it go there
right you want to let go
gotta bottle it up
you gotta get take that out i was not so
up
uh i like when that was anderson al gets
him down when he gets to the single
when he gets to the single to the bottom
don't give up don't let him get on your
back son
i i think he's wearing this is he
winning this yes brian all right he's
not winning this peter no peter peterson
yeah i think better is going to win this
bether's going to win beth are young
uh that's a granby roll but it's not
working right get out you're going to
get downstairs stand up there's nothing
there
i don't know why put your foot up peter
doesn't put his [ __ ] hooks in here
dude you're in the spot right now get
your head on the fence like you've been
doing oh my gosh you got to lose this
what do you do just let him up and start
playing bang on him bang on him here he
has that championship do you not need to
do melody oh boy
it really is going to come down to the
first round
yeah
bless you brendan bless you brandon
bless you brandon and bless you i'll
just remain sterling oh
not enough though not enough
that was a good [ __ ] fight dude it
was yeah i'll jermaine definitely in
people's respect there i think that
better won that yeah
that's a mentality just be a split i
think he has to be asleep i see i'm i'm
with jen i like his split here but you'd
probably give it if if i'm the judge you
probably give it to yon 3-2 i think he
fought a very dependable
first one
he fought a great fight algerman should
be very proud
[ __ ] dude
i would love for fighters sucks for
fighters in the job
oh yeah that's true
i don't know man
i don't know peter you don't get paid
like that my friend no that's not the
way the game works
occasionally every once in a while daddy
dana will say okay you know what it was
a good fight if you're if you're already
a belt holder they they give you the
benefit of the doubt here and if you
haven't won decisively no no no are you
from the 40s i believe that that's what
they do no they don't they're you you
got to decipher you beat the [ __ ] no you
just got to beat them do you think that
better yan won this
uh it depends how you judge that first
round
yeah and if you really want to get into
a bit here yarn was pretty much the
champion already bether yeah he was you
know what
why is we've had three decisions even
though hamza gilbert was fantastic he's
great fun he's a great friend kenzie
dern uh tiny tornado great that was
great too great fighters mark matson
vince
pitcho decision
a lot of decisions
symphony and strikes takedowns
takedown's attempt to 22. look at the
ground control okay
yeah you know what
you guys
i don't know
brian ground control okay ground control
is very important brandon i'm not gonna
lie to you but i will say this um and al
germain took to take downs 22. you've
got to give them that
uh two takedowns you know what al jamie
won this fight
um
they're going to get the fight that's
how it goes the first round dude yeah
it's all in the first round yeah i think
they're going to give it to to uh
algae
oh gee
algae
they are watch this big algae lg uh i i
don't know man i'm going
can you guys hear someone can you guys
hear it over there yeah yeah
read it off is it a split decision or no
yeah over here
oh yeah the first one peter yawn
you gotta turn you gotta turn down so we
don't get yeah
college man
wow
that moment right there i'm in control
you
know
people's parlays because this fight's
[ __ ] up yeah he did a great job man
that's a [ __ ] good deal
do you know how relieved he is after all
the [ __ ] the internet through him not
being the real champ
bad [ __ ]
it's hard to argue that he didn't but
the thing is though look like i said he
came in super relaxed he i felt like he
had nothing to prove everyone hated him
already he played the heel his whole
this whole camp he was on the internet
going oh man me and my belt oh you know
i'm looking for like crazy he was doing
the crit he was doing the cringe [ __ ] it
was so awesome he backed it up back he
was just like you know what [ __ ] it no
one likes me anyways they're all mad at
me
i thought he came in was being so
relaxed he fought really well look you
got to give the guy credit man his take
down you gotta you gotta give his
campaign
without mixing it up man hey
i read that guy more than anybody
especially on my show i read him more i
was like man the acting really got me it
bugged me that he was like oh i won the
title oh no look at his mom that
bothered me but the rest of it though
good stuff man good [ __ ] good for him
look at his mom jenny look at this girl
i told you not a girl she's a dime super
dumb
that's a big deal hey floyd
yeah
yeah i tried hollering at her i will
[ __ ] take you down and smash destroy
it good for him he bought a great fight
dude he's really great fighting really
good
we're gonna see we're gonna see part
three never like that's the part tj's
next it's gotta be yeah it's gonna be
cj's guaranteed next title shot
what happened
wait wait so we're saying you believe
that dana says he just called out 50
cents
he called out 50 cents he said he wants
to be on power
power the show that gianni's on
christian's brother oh look and they
call out tj bro he has no eyebrow now
because of all the cuts he has he's a
killer he's a stud dude he's a st he's
that guy's a [ __ ]
twister
he's calling out tj right now saying
come here yes that's a great shot fight
he's a stud who wins it tj
tv
it's a great fight style let's give me a
tough fight for him
but i think if you put tj and peter i
think peter has a good chance of beating
tj yeah yeah stop stop stop man styles
make match-ups
there's your mk guy
he's the translator yeah he said
i think he's his manager too
like actual manager
they have the same like that's so funny
structure
they really do and the hair the hair
like tips in the fruit
if you just had glasses yeah identical
nose and everything look at the nose the
nose is pointy
brennan's talents in this is so freaking
crazy he he actually figures out exactly
what someone looks like and identifies
so you call that all the time we call
that not having anything to do with else
with your time
but he's so good at it
sorry more useless
daddy daddy's got some quads on him oh
yeah sorry these things got me through
the tough mudder daddy's
oh yeah
those are real
look at that it's a great fight man
wow
wow he did a really good job of uh
of timing his shots whether he was
taking it for serious or not or just for
the movement did a really good job of
mixing those up dude it's great how he
got to the single and ran to the double
and went to his back yeah yeah yeah yeah
because he had no shot other than that
he couldn't just blast double or just
single leg
chain wrestling was on point yeah
amazing
he must be so relieved dude
he fought a great fight man his camp
came like with a game plan too
i mean a hell of a game plan it was
phenomenal [ __ ] ray longo
good for him man
amazing
that's such a big deal
god damn
all right b what do you want to bet on
this green zombie
uh you know what buddy i'm feeling i'm
feeling a little froggy i might leap i
might leave to uh
i might take the zombie
what no that's who i am oh sorry
i'll take bokonovsky there you go um and
i'm gonna say that he's in volkanovsky
because he punches so [ __ ] hard a lot
harder than korean zombie you don't
think so no no no god no you know what
you're talking about though do you not
right but he's faster he's got better
wrestling he's better than everything
but he's powers he's a better activator
better kicked in wrestling will be the
key he's a better mixed martial art dude
he's a better fighter i'm gonna i'm
gonna i'm going volkanovsky round three
i'll say volcanowski right before
peter green can get it done
you think korean gets okay so you want
to go what do you want to do it has to
be in the first round for my zombie
so you're saying if he doesn't win the
first round yeah it's a game so nothing
it's going to get you got to remember
man look zombie was winning every second
of every minute of that fight with
diarrhoea
okay he got knocked out with one second
left he dominated that fight like
you know what you know what's going to
do to [ __ ]
yaya rodriguez yeah yeah you're looking
good to max
good fight yeah
i mean it was a tough [ __ ] fight
so styles make match-ups so we're
we're comparing them but
zombies i think just i think
i think errors are hard i think our is a
pretty tough match for volk
head kicks leg kicks all those things
the spinning back kicks all the
arrangements rangy
good that's a calf kick like yeah don't
get me wrong volks got good takedowns
great ground a pound but yeah there's no
slouch he's not these he's got to take
down because after what i saw
volkanovsky did with uh [ __ ] brian
ortega oh
dude what a fight dude that was i mean
if you look at that fight though the
fight the fight wasn't that they had
their round three and round like round
five those were the good rounds i just
watched the other day rounds one and two
weren't that exciting milk was kind of
winning the fight it was kind of taking
over then round three happened you're
like oh [ __ ] yeah that made the fight
trouble yeah that made the fight right
there
so over under four and a half rounds
minus 140 for uh the great inside the
distance plus 140. yes yeah i would take
out 1900 i take the under
i take the under easy under four and a
half yeah you have me too yeah
so what i would do is i'd put a grand on
the under and then i'll put a grand on
knockout korean zombie plus 900.
because the only way
wins early
this is true play more play around with
that more but that place is packed yeah
i know it's amazing
he's awesome yeah he's awesome i do man
i do i like you once you move down there
i got your
i got seven years homie
seven years now are you okay are your
kids exhibiting the kind of athleticism
you are you have
your children
okay
okay
you shake it is that yes okay that's
okay that's okay you're a professional
athlete it's very rare
very rare um they they show a lot of
want
they have they have the work ethic
determination they don't have daddy's
bone structure and
not so much okay not yet
because you made it with a
smaller gallery well he was he was in
that damn thing for so long man oh my
god and dude ortega submission ago the
most dangerous in the division good god
yeah i just saw you how did he get out
of this good job change direction
you made it with an asian
i was like good job change of direction
i wouldn't say asians don't have good
genetics but she's smaller she's really
smart what type of asian yeah she's
taiwanese
and are the kids smart
very very smart there you go very very
so trade-off though i don't know i'll
take uh brains over yeah 100 percent
100 percent you want a dumbass 100 and
and i'll be honest with you man like we
have our issues but she is a very
concerned and caring parent like she she
loves the [ __ ] out of those kids which i
respect i really appreciate
i guess you're better though you know
yeah for sure otherwise you know yeah
otherwise what are we doing
what are we doing
i just i wake up in the middle and i
just hear this
my girl's kissing my baby's face she's
just not she's just like going no no no
she's got my baby my baby's all wrapped
in a swaddle like a little burrito and
she's like
i'm like what are you doing she goes i
just have to sometimes
so [ __ ] cute this guy's an animal god
the kid is so black
wait what i say i know it's a recessive
thing i'm sure no i'm sure nothing
i'm sure it's i'm sure it's your girl no
because no she's very white but i know i
heard that it's what are you no we're
looking
we're looking forward to jamal calling
growing up
look man it's my childhood i'm just
saying that uh
there's something
there
remember he goes come on how long do we
pretend the water doesn't beat off those
kids here yeah
he cuts up the sausages some of those
movies you couldn't do today because
people are supposed to oh you couldn't
make that it's like [ __ ] you know
dude he had uh he's bipolar uh schizo
yeah yeah you couldn't do that i mean
best part is he would after they have
sex he goes to the bathroom and starts
pissing all over the wall how about the
guy
no no he goes over there you said you'd
eat whale blubber for amigos she'll be
eating whale blubber all right as soon
as i free willy
he's that the yeah yeah small guy
how about that the guy from the daily
show was making a joke about it was like
a pro gay joke and some woman walks on
stage at columbia university
no but the other guy who's indian and
she goes i don't think i don't think
you're entitled yeah i don't think
you're entitled to make these jokes they
dragged them off stage oh my god that
dude that is insane i'll tell you what
else is insane is how clean my nuts are
thank you my friends at manscape the
global leader and below the waist
hygiene and they're turning men's shower
dreams into their favorite routine with
the all new ultra premium collection
this is a all-in-one hygiene skin and
hair bundle is designed to upgrade the
everyday man's shower routine from head
to toe your skin hair and balls deserve
this save big by going to manscape.com
for 20 off and free shipping with the
code cfc listen you got lavron cologne
infused ultra premium body wash you got
hit listen a two-for-one shampoo
conditioner you got freaking uh
applying the manscaped aluminum free
material
deodorant so you don't smell like gosh
you have dry skin cool we got your
hydrating body moisturizer spray i could
use right now on my face apply a
manscape lip balm if your lips are dry
like talons and last but not least we're
using a lawnmower 4.0 electric trimmer
to just shave everything off the hair up
on your shoulders your back
them nuts there's like there's a
flashlight on it so you can do it in the
dark it's the elite trimmer it's
designed to trigger
20 off and free shipping with code cfcs
landscape.com you know what if you guys
want 20 off plus free shipping with the
code cfc at manscape.com we'll give you
20 off and free shipping with the code
cfc manscape.com it's time to get wet
get clean with your new manscaped shower
routine see how that rhymes yes because
me and desantis care about your nuts
yeah
that should be his sold
the senses keep him around keep him
shiny and keep him at him
chin are you nervous right now hey
what's what's
what's the deal with why they're not
giving henry
the flight that he wants yeah because i
think he's losing too much money he
wants a million dollars more than that
it's gotta be more than that other
people have a million dollars he wants a
million dollars a fight plus he wants
pay-per-view numbers
so what's wrong with that i think the
ufc looks at and i would he deserves
more than a minute
way more than that yeah i think i think
ufc looks at the numbers the numbers
aren't there too yeah but i think this
though too when he left after he won the
ban on my title that put a like if you
went like they don't want another gsp
situation uh yeah jesus yeah
you win like oh you won the 45-pound
title against volk now you're gonna dip
out again
the [ __ ] i'd love to see him first of
all at 35
i mean
i'd like to see him come back to 35.
three division champ would be six yeah i
mean fighting both him and aldro
i'll join taking him down no nobody's
telling him i'm gonna take him no i i
should his name is dj i think cejudo
beats everybody dude that guy's here
see it yeah bottom left tate does that
there you go yep i saw that one ball guy
looks like the guy from uh weird science
did you guys notice that
i didn't see him how great was that
movie weird science weird science
[ __ ]
grey movie wasn't even that chicken
there kelly kelly brooke
i worked with brock i did a movie with
her before she was gross like when she
was like still she's beautiful yeah she
when i watched the movie it was [ __ ]
gorgeous probably that was probably 15
years ago it's a movie you'll never see
i can't remember but she told me some
stories she was married to stephen
lebron uh
he looks
many many years is that serious many
years when he was like on under siege
and [ __ ] yeah she didn't she didn't have
the best things to say about him
i can only imagine the weird things that
happened who's this
uh kelly lebrock who was married to
stevenson can you pull her up she's been
weird so is she
oh
she was gentle she was married she was
so hot dude oh she looks so amazing look
at her oh my god
what the [ __ ]
such a great accent too and she's
british too
you know we can talk about british
elizabeth hurley oh my god
the new british bombshell is there like
a new british actress that's just a
killer she's a good person no she was a
class-act kelly bro
okay okay okay i get it
yeah he's uh he's um they both look
insane there yeah he's he she said
something but he's so tall he's so much
taller than i thought i thought he was
you know he lives in russia uh-huh he's
like who does stevenson
oh really he's like in the war did he
just like deport him
back i remember when brian thought
stevenson was actually fighting in the
russian oh my gosh fire the kitty goes
dude he's fighting russian war and
brought up an instagram pic that rogan
posted and i shunned both of you
fake news yeah
yep that was fun oh my gosh but i would
put it back i'm proud of you for that
thanks buddy
thank you have you ever met steven
seagal oh my gosh and he was the
weirdest did he give you any advice on
fighting no but he was really tall and
bloated yeah
hey how come you don't ever come to san
jose to do shows i'm going to uh in
september so
i'll let you know for sure i flew i flew
uh i'll show you chris lytle fought over
there me too uh whenever we flew into
sydney i took every goddamn drug known
to man to go to sleep and i slept for an
hour and a half oh wow like i took two
ambien i took everything and i couldn't
fall asleep it was terrible yeah
well
what's that like when you fly from east
to west
you have a harder time adjusting to the
time that you find west i don't it has
like we were talking about they just
study for football players they were
flying from like new york to san
francisco to play yeah they had a harder
time adapting to it because
basically you're waking up it's [ __ ]
four in the morning yeah yeah three you
know four or five in the morning right
here
and then you're going to bed at like six
and you're like [ __ ] and you play at
seven o'clock nine o'clock you know
you're playing
six seven o'clock at night yeah
whatever it was so that's where you
gotta take half an hour you know what i
mean guys
i just freeze
oh [ __ ]
he's [ __ ] he's a stun man yeah he's
awesome
he is a [ __ ] monster
you should be a rugby player yeah 240
pounds
how tall is he
uh four foot he's five one yeah is he
he's gotta be five one two forty there's
no you're both five six five six still
like a [ __ ] kangaroo five six five
seven five six no he's not five seven
five six
look at him geez
look at that i don't know bubba i i have
skeptical hippo eyes i'm gonna say 200
pounds no no no look at him look at that
he's thick look at those legs you know
they throw around numbers like 240. i'm
giving him two
225. yeah yeah really came from him i'm
giving him 205. oh my god that looks
about go to when he was beef really
beefy thick guy
there's that picture of him uh like his
fat face and he then it shows him
chiseled
if you go down right there right there
see that
right there uh yeah see that's the
second one
yeah yeah yeah yeah no no no next one
next one yes look at him there that's
him well he was overweight that's it
very overwhelming he's 240 yeah yeah
yeah okay that makes sense it's 240.
look that make sure you're on the left
looking [ __ ] off his face looks like
mine
dude my rookie picture well that kind of
looks like you
my rookie picture is the worst picture
of all time like i was 315 pounds
we couldn't find that
baby took it off the internet yeah
strongest guy in the locker room was
typically samoan white guy black guy
usually michael strahan for the giants
is that right michael strain was amazing
dude that's strong you wanna hear a
story about this yes please so at the
end of the season they always do a three
fifteen test right seven two twenty two
and a quarter so everybody will kill two
and a quarter twice okay
225 but like guys who are big
like i can do it over 35 times now yeah
that makes sense yeah so two and a
quarter is not real it's really the yeah
so 315 is a real test okay so at the end
of the season they do a 315 test uh and
nobody gets in they bench do whatever
right and people will bench i don't know
anything from from so benchmark 15. yeah
many times and you'll bench it from 10
on the bottom end strand 20. stranded
6'5 and he hasn't so stray does whatever
number god knows what right something's
stupid and then a free agent
rookie o lineman comes in and he's like
listen i'm going to crush 315. i'm going
to crush it so just let me do 405. so
they and straight like sets all the
records all the time it's way straighted
i didn't know that so they hit they they
put four or five on the bar and dude
does x amount of times right and they go
to the chart and they're like you know
the projected max chart blah blah blah
holy [ __ ] you're stronger than stray
blah blah strays in like on the same
floor in the the luncheon room eating
eating food whatever their lunches they
go oh [ __ ] they all freak out go real
straight they're stronger than you blah
blah the dude puts on his food goes in
there doesn't do a warm set i don't know
probably 25 minutes later that he did he
did his work
goes in there takes 405.
one more rep than the dude did puts it
back i mean we're talking though uh i do
probably 13 14 yeah at four at 405.
jesus and straight just put it put it up
jesus dude it's so that was with the
giants
isaac sopawago from
49ers i think you came from hawaii or
something like that yeah yeah yeah
something maybe um so he was a a
noseguard
so ignorantly strong so in the office
moana bro and and he does for sure in
the uh offseason we were doing
sets of 16 for whatever reason nfl we're
doing sets of 16.
this [ __ ] dude he does 315
for all three sets and picks it up
himself and sets it up himself every
single set of 16. jesus christ i i've
never seen you straight
for three sets of 16. jesus christ
didn't need help and didn't need help
what a weird strength that's a terrible
strength remember remember brian young
why back brian young came from notre
dame he was a 49ers
defensive end tackle monster dude this
dude would do he was 320 pounds he would
do wide grip pull ups with 120 pound
dumbbell in his feet
and just kill him forwards backwards
just like that you've got a 300 pounder
yes dude he was disgusting disgusting
remember
ken norton jr broke his compound
fractured his leg he came in to finish
off a pile and by was standing there and
he his helmet hit his chin and compound
fractures this is after he came back
from that jesus dude he was sick the
49ers had ignorant strength you you're
you're really strong though aren't you
no you're not no um i'm athletic i'm not
strong
you're not like weight room strong no
not at all i'm functional strong yeah
yeah
you're the lightest i've ever seen
anybody on their feet at your size yeah
a little bit
lightest
um but like dude there were some people
that i saw that were just
there was a dude we had at purdue named
chucky okobe i never saw this dude miss
a squat never ever ever i don't care how
much they put on the bar dude never miss
a squat jesus i mean i you could be 750
pounds 100 pounds i have no idea but he
never missed a squat that's like a rich
incognito i looked at him and i when i
shook his hand is my hand didn't go
around his palm my hand see this i'm not
joking you see this how does your thumb
do that because i broke it like wow look
at that i punched somebody i'm up f i'm
a tough kid but i i went to shake hands
and it was raised up a little higher
give me an angle on that thing
no like this here yeah it disconnected
it disconnected bubba yeah yeah hold up
brandon i went like that i hooked
somebody agent mckee in volk
i'm not soldier he's a real the real
deal you're not sold on him i'm not sold
on my i don't know i don't know why he's
killing people
he's the real deal man there we go
oh you know beltor just signed pico
yeah yeah every time yeah he took a
minute what happened
did he take did he take some time off or
what uh
and we bet whiskey remember oh three
thousand with if korean zombie wins you
get a bottle of pappy's if voted
rocked him
something else
he's
volk is a [ __ ] savage
friend zombie though he's been here
though you know he has experience and
he's got a good haircut
remember when korean zombie had his arm
like it dislocated do you remember that
again
oh god that was awful
dude he's gonna be that's important yeah
you beat the [ __ ] parade back in the
day that's
before you started growing right hair
out he became much better
yeah he's a dying piece now yeah who's
this poor employee remember he was bald
forever he had like the big head
and now he's been with this girl since
middle school has he really yeah i like
him so much he's [ __ ] such a great
kid he's always at bellator fights too
he's always cornering people
he's so cool man he's a really good dude
i call him a kid he's he's getting older
now but he's like
he he i went outside
i went out the train with frankie
for the second benson fight and he was
there and i was like how the [ __ ] do you
make 145. he was walking around like 180
something right yeah oh my good god he
walks around at 183. he's so big he has
really good bourbon too
does he yeah really he sent me a bottle
it's really nice what is it called
do you remember chins we haven't
called diamonds have it in the shop show
on set
i mean
that's why it's really good hot sauce
really mm-hmm his hot sauce is pretty
popular oh my god
this is a
fight
volkanovsky is he can just he connects
like nobody's business and you think
with those short arms would be hard he's
got so much speed yeah dude
he's got he's also got really good
angles man yeah
yeah you know if zombie's going to lose
this if he tries to do to exchange like
he's called rare chin i'm surprised he's
not [ __ ] kicking me yeah rare stash
rear stashes
he's got some ears to him in that hat
yeah bourbon or whiskey bourbon it says
whiskey here really i thought it was the
burger oh bourbon whiskey yeah
rear stash
good for him man i like what he's doing
he's doing a lot of good stuff yeah yeah
100 hot sauce got his bourbon whiskey
he's got the charity he puts a lot back
man
yeah
good little cake even theoretics really
yeah both from what louisiana yeah oh
yeah did he get rocked or he just
stepped off was zombie rocked yeah
zombie guy he looked hot twice right now
good job
he's bleeding yeah he's bleeding he's
getting [ __ ] he's gonna get
nobody
he's got crazy speed and his arms are
like stretch arms oh they're just
touching they catch you they find you
dude volcanos you're trying to get him
out of there
well spokanovsky's reach
i feel like he's got longer arms than
his body he's just faster when he gets
in crazy
zombies not a fast guy no yeah you know
vulcanized gotta be powerful too man for
him if he was that big he's got muscle
memory from being that big ground and
pounds gonna be vicious right now 71
inches yeah that's pretty long yep
chain click on it says who has the
longest reach in the ufc is still john
jones god but imagine yeah
dan christian oh that's dan chris that's
way forever ago
stephanie retired so john does that 84
and a half
damn chris you should train with us he
was from santa no he's from somewhere in
indiana he's a champion once in a while
was huge he was so big dude
but you want to know the truth we
stopped training with him for a reason
wasn't very good
he had uh
he had he he's talked about it openly he
had two kids in in
new mexico and he was like i just left
him and we were like oh [ __ ] what
happened
zombie twice now twice now from the
headshot yeah he got hit with a
two-piece combination then as soon as he
got back up he got laid kicked inside to
his butt he is [ __ ] yeah zombie up
and he he's going to keep going this
pace that speed difference is for real
dude alex the pace going no don't blow
your nose inverse max next huh
jeez they didn't show max hallway i
figured max would be there i figured
it'd be an alternative in case somebody
misses wait he was supposed to be but
he's not there huh we didn't see him
though yeah
god if you're his corner what are you
saying to the korean zombie hey you got
to move your head you can't just take it
does it surprise you though this the
fight that was the main event
i thought i thought the last fight would
have been the main event
yeah this would have been this should
have been the co the other one should
have been oh yeah that's a good hook
he drops him he drops them though coming
up that's a good point there too
right here he drops him right here one
oh and he hits him again right here boom
right hand oh no not that one there's
another that wobbled him
one time he's not doing much he gets
dropped in one of these situations right
there
boom boom all that mist there that's a
nightmare oh
i thought he dropped him too he did he
dropped into him
he got back up he dropped him you know
that was like a really good chin so he
can well yeah
the best though yeah
i mean it would suck to be known to be
able to take a serious ass with that
yeah yeah yeah it's a tough gift yeah he
is ranked number four in the world
though
[ __ ] remember uh who was it leonard
garcia
he was known for like just taking yeah
punishment and then remember
one second left in the first round or
something wasn't it first twister ever
but do you remember do you remember
their first fight though their first
fight was [ __ ] phenomenal the second
one twisted them in the ufc yeah
zombie's a badass zombie's uh not moving
his back foot on he's not doing anything
he's not really excited on his job he's
just he's just not
speeds different athletes just a
different athlete the volcano is a
different
athlete second round for the twister
yeah
that's a nice little bro you gotta know
your guys's footage bro
come on man
i don't know man
oh too slow it's just too slow
everything's getting beat to the punch
every single way
i heard him more than they hit her
in zombie there that like yeah but look
at how red his leg is nice
see why you throw that jab you're so far
away and you're not you know they're
really worried about korean zombies
shoulder forever and they took this
fight yeah oh yeah
zombies getting [ __ ] up he is he's
getting [ __ ] up yeah he's just waiting
off he changes your career man he
[ __ ] hits you too much
[ __ ] breaks your face and there's so
much power in that bed oh god damn man
in and out he's so hard he is
you can't go from being 240 though he's
like he's just
excellent he's got excellent hands he's
so good how heavy is that featherweight
45 45. crazy good hands though
and
looks good up there yes oh nice
that was a nice straight left though oh
oh then he got hit with the right he's
just too slow huh dude that dude's left
cheekbone's gonna be beat the hell well
that's what's so good about volkowski he
just can stay composed in that [ __ ]
pocket
you throw twice and he comes back with a
[ __ ]
disaster
look at that
this
high level [ __ ] always changing his
stance
pain me ass hey do these governors
travel with secret service oh
yeah
yes he's got yeah
like one
he's got at least four guys
trying to kill him oh my god oh
yeah i would have taken this i would
have taken him
don't don't throw
zombie landed there though yeah be
careful with the zombie now he's
shooting in the zombie that's i wouldn't
have done that i would have sat back and
just not gotten greedy dude the zombie
has the best mma shirt of all time that
black shirt that tricosta made the green
zombie on it it's [ __ ] lit black with
the teal and pink yeah yeah i rocked it
nonstop
what fight was that after
because it wasn't always called
was that what that was i think it was
after lena garcia it was the after it
was after the twister because then
remember dana wore it on the weigh-ins
or something like that i thought it was
after a hell of an hour at the weigh-ins
yeah yeah
that sure i think it was after the
twisties
now zombie has his own gear
not the same material though is it jen
he promotes on those hard
cotton shirts now and by the way jay
park
k-pop star he's the one that actually
facilitated giving us all that yeah i
love you he's awesome so he he was in in
the uh 24 7 for them yeah he's speaking
he's talking about english so he helps
out a lot yeah he's great he's a huge
star in korea and yeah now here too yeah
so talk to me who who is jay park he's a
he was in a korean pop band
back in the day before you know bts is
the biggest right now right but jay park
was in like one of the biggest bands
ever at that time when he was doing the
camera are they still bigger though no
so they kind of like died down but he
started blowing up he left the band
and started blowing up yeah so like
johnny's got a jump ship you know he's
like the beyonce huh like justin
timberlake like yeah yeah beyonce yeah
oh my god was that inside trippy to see
it no he stepped he stepped to the
outside and tripped him but he punched
kind of pushed him over off balance
volkanovsky is doing work yeah he's just
a nightmare he's just a buzzsaw that's a
just seriousness it just kind of hurts
so much oh my god that could hurt just
hurts oh this [ __ ] just hurts you
it's crazy because the last three fights
have been such crazy mismatches but
they've been good fights geez this has
been the only one where like god damn
his technique he's just [ __ ] really
good man
there was talk about peter young
fighting him for a while and it's like i
don't know man
he's [ __ ] too powerful
beyond's way too small dude i wouldn't
mind seeing [ __ ] conor mcgregor
they've trained again
connor's never making 145 again ever
ever ever no but babe [ __ ] honestly
you go out to 55. no
what about him fighting what about him
he's starting to hit him fighting
too small connor shut the [ __ ] up
connor's never fighting i think he's
fighting 45-55 ever again
he's like 190 right yeah but he's huge
fighting a lot of whiskey in there a lot
of whiskey numbers a lot dude he's
sitting on the ground not on the on the
stool
yeah
that's common
it's a tough fight for man
do you think that's even is is that even
on the radar conor fighting osmond just
connor gets to find anybody once it's on
dana's radar yeah it's on dana's radar
wow you think that's gonna happen
we'll see i think dana should entertain
jake paul versus connor
that'd be great
i mean i i think it's gonna happen
regardless yeah so if i'm dana i want a
piece of that pie i want in on the
business i agree the oven's already
pre-heated dude
jake paul
is in the game
of my show the other night yeah
he's the biggest star in the game right
now it makes no sense not to lure him in
i didn't see he was all the way back and
came to the green room after
anyone else too i'll tell you about jake
paul
he's hungry jake paul wants to scrap
tell me so you get a dude in there that
really wants to let his nuts hang you
can't say no to that dude but if i'm the
ufc like it's gonna dude if you guys
it's gonna happen dude might as well be
part of it might as well make some money
on homie saw some tickets
dude you've done it before cm punk
yeah it's not like this i'm rewriting
[ __ ] history here okay mickey go
vicky golf ate his ass oh he yells quick
two yeah
yeah mickey goals no punk no that's a
tough fight for st punk they were they
didn't want him to win look at this look
at this
he lost he got tko tonight
by uh he did yeah [ __ ]
by who he face planted yeah
still a solid fighter but you know it's
tough
geez sorry guys
you find it 70
i think he is yeah
who's that mickey gall mm-hmm
70. yeah
he lost
yeah face playing huh yeah that's
awesome he's also another good uh he has
a serious show i think he's good on
radio is he is he yeah he's good man
what happened there
look at this
look at zombies korean zombie there's no
quit in the zombies hey there's some
head movement right there
he just just not the ass what right this
is the third round we said four and a
half yeah four and a half yes i still
like four and a half man
it's tough to make hey we we all we
busted our nut didn't we we're all tired
all of us like those fights took it out
of us and now we're like we're just
fighting i can't well this one's such an
ass whoop but it's tough to get inside
of it
i feel bad for zombie dude yeah hey man
he's coming back yeah he's doing better
this third you have a lot of faith
he hasn't put a mark on his face though
but i'll give the zombie though he's not
backing down how much how much gel is in
his hair that hasn't moved
like it's literally said the part is the
same that's fantastic yeah yeah i mean
he looks cool too with the part he he
looks like a like a 55 year old
insurance salesman with that haircut
that uses shoe polishes hair dye
from like the 50s oh it's a it's a very
world war ii vibe you feel me
oh yeah
bruce lee oh my god what's going down
what a drop in he's going down daddy
what a drop in
good job he's holding himself he's a
savage man look at that that's great
defense that's a great job with the
zombie together
everybody everybody's telling us
everybody's kind of like all decisions
the guy in the bow tie feels like we do
right now
yeah
herb dean got to wear a bow tie look at
him there he is oh that guy yeah he
kills people isn't that uh who's the
jackass guy am i wrong john knoxville
yeah he's not dying are you sure no that
guy's in the child point oh no yeah he
kills people he's into child porn you
don't wear a bowtie like that not like
little kids all right well that's not
that's not that's not too many rumors
but he definitely
has people in his basement you know what
i'm saying dude
oh
oh my god move your head with coming in
dude he hasn't moved his head his whole
career
he's not going to start now what he does
his name's the zombie oh look at this
guy oh look at this guy [ __ ] try to
more me to just a big old plate of meat
or something like that
hey slide that over here captain let's
get weird
did you did you bring the barbecue sauce
too i'm going to get it thanks brother
why if i jump on your dc's get you some
man
let me slide some on over here captain i
mean zombies hanging in there
yeah you want some oh yeah oh yeah oh
yeah
b how excited are you for my special
april 28th i can't wait buddy is it 29th
or 8th 28th 28th glad you told me that
28. you go poppy i'm ready 30 minutes of
latin
fire coming your way
that's what you just went to 29th
i'm excited buddy no
where's it at
i shot in uh dallas but it's gonna be uh
youtube i have a i have a surprise 30
minutes 30 minutes i got a surprise
special guest opening for me uh
maybe what made you do
you know what i uh
i was
waiting i got the okay from a few
networks you guys would all know
and then uh it just i was like all right
well what are you gonna do for me they
told me i'm like i feel like i can do
that myself so i called mike i was like
hey can you get billboard sick yeah like
can you do this he's like gambling
then why would i do all this promotion
oh my god oh my god
oh my god it's just not good he that's a
straight ass yeah he'll make it to the
fourth round though
oh no they might stop it they might stop
it no oh
he's going i don't know why you weren't
oh melt's not good
again
god dawg oh my dude he's
he's do you let him go back out there if
you're his corner no no
no you're not winning the fight no i
mean you haven't won the second of this
fight i just would never why let me try
again
yeah you have you haven't won
the two meetings you need that sauce
don't you that's awesome
be cool
be cool
anybody want that seasoning shake on
there yeah
that barbecue sauce something else
though
the handy market
he does this to everybody's face he
[ __ ] up everybody's face he really does
volkanovsky just [ __ ] you up and
it takes years off your career
a little bit for you though
that that ortega fight was so hard to
watch
just a killer dude he's a [ __ ] killer
he'll have a mark on his not a mark on
his [ __ ] face dude he just stays
there oh my god look at his speed dude
he's just a nightmare yeah
look at the legs it all comes from his
hips and his legs who's that guy with
the red beard
and got a lot of jewelry on i've seen
him before he's an athlete
he's an athlete
they're in jacksonville so maybe he
plays for the jacksonville jaguars y'all
know who that guy looks like a baseball
player
yeah
i think he was
dude
i couldn't name
three jacksonville jaguars terrible team
terrible
i can name one trevor lawrence that's it
is mile gear miles garrison with him no
he's with the browns yeah yeah yeah
he's always been the brown guy yeah no
he was a jackass wasn't it
no he got drafted who's the other guy
jesus christ
oh gosh all right stop the fight
good job
good job
good job great job good job
he absolutely annihilated him all right
give me my five t's that was under four
and a half rounds too wow
wow
good job
i'm really proud of that
is that though i don't know
that's a good stop good job i mean
zombie's obviously gonna lose zombie's
too tough he's never given up no you got
to stop that fight
good job that's a great job
really great job well you guys know you
guys are fighters so you guys know
you just don't want zombie taking too
much punch of course not back from it
yeah i remember in those type of
situations when guys take them out of
damage
they leave a part of their life in there
correct so just let them let them their
career is never the same yeah
right oh that's awful [ __ ] ah wow good
job good stop good job such a mismatch
yeah
oh look at this look what happens to
your brain stem look at that oh dude i
really want to see max holloway
volkanovsky though
should be next huh
yeah i kind of want to see henry ceruto
invoked though
sorry kind of want to see that more than
anything
i've seen max couple max invoke a couple
of times
who's next for who's next for
volkanovsky man good card even though
most decisions but they're stacked it
was fun do that dern fight was so
exciting like normally dude
gilbert burns was fantastic
we really learned a lot about hanzo [ __ ]
yeah yeah that is what he calls him
that's a very short man but he is a
[ __ ]
nightmare mighty [ __ ] mouse
wow he is a stud
yeah good stoppage by [ __ ] he's
probably he's got to be five four five
five just a little ball of fury it's
just a ball of fury bro
new zealand
i mean he and chandler wouldn't be a bad
fight man chandler's 55 i know but you
know what so i'll take that fight
chandler's a huge 55er it's such a
stupid idea you think so yeah i think
that'd be a big
channel like that 80. well you know what
he could put that weight he's higher
than that
yeah
he's that big
never happening no
you might as well say francis in ghana i
don't know dude god brothers together i
don't know
both got no chance of beating him the
chandler yeah i agree it's never going
to happen yeah you're right because chad
can't everybody oh
no i'm saying he makes up to 15. he
fights 55 if he fights 55
like chandler by the time he steps in
the cage it's like 185. also volkswagen
is not a big 45 nice you're undersized
in every single fight
it's such a stupid idea so thick though
it does so strong and hits hard yeah
hit the showers
hey you pulled some money down you know
there is a difference in that 55 that
extra 10 pounds
they're big
dude
i gotta admit man you were right though
you were right we kind of blew our wads
in the first two we got a little tired
guys we all did god
i ran 15k you did that
i played beats volleyball doesn't count
against against a bunch of athletic gays
yep three white guys they were younger
than me i just i traveled here this
morning and i got stuck in like you know
la traffic javelin
dude i was i was what did i do i was
looking around
i haven't i've been in la like in terms
of like been downtown in probably five
six years oh downtown's happening
downtown's booming no it's booming it's
booming with homeless people though by
the way oh are you there bro
put you on a budget
jw marriott right now oh it's nice down
there it's nice but when you get out of
the water
it's the walking dead she's bad yeah
it's just tent city yeah that's bad yeah
skittles awful very bad
and you you're staying downtown for
bellator yeah bellator's on mud so big
john or wayne air podcast is hosting the
oppressor on monday on youtube and
what's the fight so we have the hole for
the san jose card is nem conference cory
anderson aj mckee and patricio is next
friday
that one and then the week after we've
got two hawaii fights so we're releasing
the bantamweight tournament which is
coming up so you guys are doing in
hawaii yeah we're going to hawaii so you
get to go to hawaii yep never mad at
that never mind
nope nope so we're doing that and then
uh you know cyborg's fighting over there
eliminates fighting over there so we've
got the cyborg
what happened
that's tough they got the translator in
there
with the [ __ ] up you got your ass
kicked today
what are you thinking it is
it's just not good for you man
[ __ ] that took a chance such a tough
night in the office
yeah he was quick man here's real quick
yeah
right
yeah too much speed
look at us you guys want to take a nap
let's take a bunch of these guys
holy [ __ ] this has been the nappy
well you're 100 correct it really it was
hard to call that fight exciting because
it was just such an [ __ ] the other
fights when they're excited and we were
popping in a buzzing it took it took all
our energy out that that was just such a
slaughter yes i thought i thought we
were done i thought rogan was like i'm
done i'm done doing these fights like
i'm done doing the interview no only if
they get knocked out yeah they get
knocked out he's like i'm not
interviewing guys he's close enough
though he likes doing that i don't know
what you're going to interview with
korean zombie on like what happened he's
like uh got my ass whooped joe uh and
every which way i got out class
not my night what do you want me to say
dude look at that [ __ ] cut he's got
to get stitched up who was that dude who
had to cut like
and it was like just
i was like an elbow or something marvin
eastman yeah
that was no there's a reason
that that that's a great reference
there's a more recent one than that an
elbow that just was gnarly ash is that
was that the mark munoz one that his boy
caught him with and he shot him on a
shot or something like that and he was
like
was that what that was it might have
been wide maneuvers look at that look at
that that was mark lewis
but there's another really bad one chin
did they have them on there
oh tj's tj let me see tj's i don't
remember that one
oh tj's was
gnarly oh that's why you said he didn't
have an eyebrow anymore yeah
yeah i mean he he's got plenty of cuts
but like that one i think that one is
bad right above the eye too he gets cut
he's got bad scratches look up look up
kane musa kane musa
[Music]
looks pretty badass when it heals though
you know he's too good dude look at how
good he is
yeah he's on point he [ __ ] just hey
if you guys are listening to us man the
plus 110 under four and a half right now
jeez plus 110. overall good night of
fights though even though
a lot of decisions on the main card four
out of the five were decisions but they
were pretty [ __ ] fun
and educational
yeah education dude you keep calm then
try to be whatever i want i hope he
fights you when he sees you
oh [ __ ] poor korean zombie dude out of
there man oh his girl's like hey let's
get the [ __ ] out or not do this anymore
right get him home get out of there man
he's got to be a star back home oh yeah
he's huge he has his own dojos out there
get him out of here that's definitely
not the way to make money no he's a
[ __ ] definitely not the way to make
it man it's gotta be weird man
he also stepped in for max holloway you
know like he's a warrior man
everyone's so sad oh volkanovsky look at
how [ __ ] humble he is oh he's a great
champion awesome awesome
i wish you'd bloom back up to 240 though
yeah
and fight france john jones
i'm sick that's it
john just the biggest jump up ever
145 240. that's probably gonna be one of
the [ __ ] sickest paintings or
whatever it is that's dope
baines are banes made yeah that's public
emily number one that's awesome yeah he
said to me was like what do you think of
this man i was like dude i want to buy
the original
right now
that's great can you get copies of that
i don't know i like that a lot man
that's dope
vicente luke muhammad that's fun
font vera they got uh charles oliveira
i'll be in [ __ ] charlotte may 5th 6th
and 7th though
[Music]
well that's it kids special drops april
28th on thick boy youtube and then next
thursday friday saturday your boy is at
stand up live in phoenix arizona
thursday friday saturday austin texas
one night only at the paramount theater
for the moon tower comedy festival of
thick boy crew is in effect and then
charlotte you're up may 5th through the
seventh come get it but special drops
april 28th
gringo poppy take it away
florida florida tip i'll see you [ __ ]
april 15 16 that's next weekend then we
got port charlotte florida i come right
back brandon i go to i go to fort myer
world's masonic comedy theater in port
charlotte near fort myer and then i got
las vegas nevada wise guys comedy club
april 28th 29th 30th and then stress
factory may 5th 6th 7th come see me new
jersey new brunswick jersey
are we doing drops now yeah yeah do it
in podcast tune in subscribe like
youtube spotify itunes you and big john
were the best to do it man thanks
brother i appreciate that man we drop on
sundays we drop on wednesday mornings
take us out boom conspiracy social club
on rock fam i don't know i mean
awesome
pretty awesome i love it i think you've
got some ideas love you some victory
let's do it
all right kids we're out thanks for
watching liking subscribing subscribe to
thick boy channel right now we love you
guys till next time we're out
you